programming throwdown episode 175 resume writing take it away patrick we i don't know that we've ever talked about it before but probably have we've talked about all the things um i every so often it ebbs and flows i have a dslr and i had recently uh upgraded to a slightly newer one but smaller than my my old setup so you know this is like a physical camera it's large has interchangeable interchangeable lens. Now, what is the SLR? Is the D digital? Oh, so D is digital. SLR is single lens reflex.
Programming Throwdown 第 175 期，简历写作。Patrick，你来开始吧。我们好像从来没聊过这个话题，但也可能聊过，毕竟我们什么都聊过。我偶尔会这样，兴趣时起时落。我有一台单反相机，最近升级了一台稍微新一点的，但比我旧的那套设备要小。你知道，这是一种实体相机，体积很大，可以更换镜头。那么，什么是单反（SLR）？D 是指数字（Digital）吗？哦，所以 D 是数字，SLR 是单镜头反光（Single Lens Reflex）。
So way back in the day, if you ever see the like old cameras, there's like two lenses, one above each other. Those were reflex cameras. In other words, you could look through and the lenses moved in synchronized fashion. But when you take the picture, the bottom lens opens up and exposes the film but the top lens is what you're focusing and composing the picture through and so these are i think they would call them tlr2 lens reflex um okay and then so they move to single lens reflex which has a mirror at a 45 degree angle behind the lens so the light shines through the lens
很久以前，如果你见过那种老式相机，上面有两个镜头，一个叠在另一个上面。那些是双镜头反光相机（TLR）。换句话说，你可以通过取景器观察，两个镜头同步移动。但当你拍照时，下面的镜头打开并曝光胶片，而上面的镜头用于对焦和构图。我想他们称之为 TLR，即双镜头反光。好吧，后来他们转向了单镜头反光，它在镜头后面有一个 45 度角的反光镜，光线穿过镜头，
bounces up into a pentagonal prism and in through the little cup at the top that you would look through. And then when you go to take the picture, the mirror drops down and exposes the film. So then they had digital SLRs where instead of exposing the film, it exposes a silicon sensor, CMOS or CCD. then actually now it's a bit of a misnomer most of the lens reflexes the mirrors popping down are gone and they're all uh mirrorless cameras and so your the lens is directly exposing the sensor pretty much all the time and then the thing on the back or the thing in the eyepiece is you know rendering the the basically it's like a monitor for the the sensor um okay but i don't know i still call them
反射到五棱镜中，然后通过顶部的取景器观察。当你按下快门拍照时，反光镜会落下，让胶片曝光。后来有了数码单反，它们不再曝光胶片，而是曝光硅传感器，即 CMOS 或 CCD。现在“单反”这个词其实有点名不副实了，大多数单镜头反光相机的反光镜结构已经消失，它们现在都是无反相机。镜头几乎一直直接对着传感器曝光，背后的屏幕或取景器里的东西，基本上就像是传感器的显示器。好吧，但我不知道，我还是叫它们
dslrs because yeah whatever uh yeah that makes sense stuck at it but yeah so the so they give better quality than like your phone that's ah so i mean that's that's the question right um and so uh my phone does pretty good i have a pretty recent iphone personally but you know i think most of the phones you know we've been in a bit of a opportunity for, I think, uh, features to equalize a bit. Um, and so I have a pretty nice phone. It has a lot of nice features, takes great pictures. If you take time to, you know, you know, compose them properly and make sure they're exposed properly. Mine has an option to, you know, do them as the raw images rather than the JPEG images. So you get more dynamic range in the colors.
单反，因为习惯了。但它们确实比手机画质更好。这就是问题所在，对吧？我的手机拍得也挺好，我个人用的是比较新的 iPhone，但我觉得大多数手机……我们现在处于一个功能趋同的阶段。我的手机很不错，有很多好功能，能拍出很棒的照片。如果你花时间去正确构图并确保曝光准确的话。我的手机有一个选项，可以拍摄 RAW 格式而不是 JPEG，这样你在色彩上能获得更大的动态范围。
It uses extra bits to store the color information. So 10 bits instead of normally 8 bits. So you can do those things. And it actually is pretty nice. But if you think about it, just in your head, the size of those lenses, the size of the chip that does it, however many megapixels they are they're still physically very very very small um and so they deal with a lot of noise issues and they make up for it by they sell so many of them the amount of dollars they can spend
它使用额外的位（bits）来存储颜色信息，通常是 10 位而不是 8 位。所以你可以做这些调整。这确实很不错。但如果你仔细想想，那些镜头的尺寸、处理图像的芯片尺寸，无论它们有多少像素，物理尺寸依然非常非常小。所以它们要处理很多噪点问题，而它们弥补这一点的方法是——因为销量巨大，它们有足够的资金
to you know do tons of software processing and have the best sensors and do all that is is a huge factor rather than you know these mirrorless cameras maybe they sell you know one-tenth one-hundredth as many as they sell you know whatever the top line phone is and so they can't spend as much but the physical size of the sensor like you mentioned can be a lot bigger so on a they call it like a full frame again going back it used to be 35 millimeter film which is 35 millimeters on the diagonal um if you have a full frame sensor which is the one i happen to have it's 35 millimeters on the diagonal i mean that's size that is like a huge percentage of my phone's total dimensions like
进行大量的软件处理，并拥有最好的传感器。这是一个巨大的因素。相比之下，这些无反相机可能销量只有顶级手机的十分之一甚至百分之一，所以它们无法投入那么多资金。但正如你提到的，传感器的物理尺寸可以大得多。比如全画幅（Full Frame），回到过去，它指的是 35 毫米胶片，即对角线 35 毫米。如果你有一个全画幅传感器，也就是我用的这种，它的对角线是 35 毫米。我的意思是，这个尺寸占我手机总尺寸的很大比例，就像
that's a big sensor um and so when you go to take take pictures if you just look at them you know in small size they they kind of they feel equivalent like if you just look at them, you know, in small size, they, they, they kind of, they feel equivalent. Like if you just pick it up and snap it, like you would with your phone, you don't really notice a difference. But again, if you take time to, you know, get a lens that is, has maybe a bigger zoom and you know, that kind of stuff, you start to realize, ah, there's a lot of, uh, more data that you can pull out. There's a lot more color. You can kind of shift around. You can kind of change the exposure because the camera doesn't when you go to take a picture you don't know what you're trying to to show and if you notice like if you go take a picture at sunset
那是一个很大的传感器。所以当你拍照时，如果你只是在小尺寸下看，它们感觉差不多。就像你随手拿起手机拍一张，你真的感觉不到区别。但如果你花时间去用一个变焦范围更大的镜头，你就会开始意识到，你可以提取出更多的数据。有更多的色彩，你可以进行调整，可以改变曝光，因为当你拍照时，相机并不知道你想展示什么。如果你在日落时拍照，
and you pull up your phone or even one of these cameras and you take a picture it's trying to adjust the white balance so you know you're not necessarily seeing the colors and it you're looking out towards a very bright part of the sky with everything else dark and so it's trying to average out across the whole scene if you now in your phone you probably have options but people rarely use them but yeah i have no idea what half those buttons do on the camera app there we go but when you have a physical camera you have all these you know buttons and you sort of like switches and dials and all that stuff is sort of immediately there and so for me it's a bit of a first world problem i guess a luxury i would say but you know you can do these things with the phone you have but if you if you're able to have one of these camera forces you into a slightly different way of thinking and what you find is
你拿出手机，或者即使是这些相机，它都会尝试调整白平衡，所以你看到的颜色不一定准确。你对着天空非常明亮的部分，而其他地方很暗，所以它会尝试对整个场景进行平均。在手机上你可能有选项，但人们很少用。我根本不知道相机应用里那一半按钮是干嘛的。但当你有一台实体相机时，所有的按钮、开关和拨盘都在那里，触手可及。对我来说，这算是一种“第一世界问题”，或者说是一种奢侈。你可以用手机做这些事，但拥有一台这样的相机，会迫使你以一种略微不同的方式思考。你会发现，
or at least i do that the actual process of taking these pictures, sort of like treating them with care, which of course takes orders of magnitude longer than clicking the auto adjust feature and posting them to, you know, family and in a group chat or you on social media or whatever. And I don't even really share these pictures anyone, but just sort of having them and sort of taking time with the content picture. So I'll take a picture of my kid, but rather than just, Hey, smile, snap, it'd be like, hang on, I'm going to take a picture, you know, and you have them sit, you know, a little nicer and you get a little bit more of a composed thing, which is how growing up, at least that's how kind of all the pictures were. No one just like rapid, you know, click, click, click, click, click. Like people would set up a picture. You would take a picture. Now you can say that's fake, but it has a certain, uh, nostalgia and specialness to it. When you go back to edit that picture, you're sort of reengaging a bit with that, that moment because you took time to kind of think through it. And then, and then
至少我是这样，拍照的过程，就像小心翼翼地对待它们，这当然比点击自动调整功能并发布到家庭群聊或社交媒体上要花多得多的时间。我甚至不怎么和别人分享这些照片，只是拥有它们，花时间去构图。我会给我的孩子拍照，而不是简单地说“嘿，笑一个，咔嚓”，我会说“等一下，我要拍照了”，让他们坐得更好一点，构图更讲究一点。这就像我小时候，所有的照片都是这样拍的。没有人会快速地“咔嚓、咔嚓、咔嚓”。人们会布置好场景，然后拍照。你可以说这是做作，但它有一种怀旧感和特殊性。当你回去编辑那张照片时，你是在重新与那个时刻互动，因为你花时间去思考了它。然后，
it's a little bit of a more of a thoughtful process. So I've been finding that interesting is, and to answer your question, I don't actually know because I treat them so differently, the force yourself to use your phone and to use it in the way where you adjust all the settings. And it's obviously not going to be as capable still. Like, you know, you can put a gigantic, absolutely gigantic lens with a huge zoom and your phone can't do that. Um, but if you shoot in the sort of normal ranges of things, if you really took time, learned a sophisticated phone parameter app and, you know, figured all that, maybe maybe they're the same. But people didn't realize they were going to happen, they end up getting captured. And just, it's just this very interesting thing that I didn't spend a
这是一个更深思熟虑的过程。所以我发现这很有趣。回答你的问题，我其实不知道，因为我对待它们的方式太不同了。强迫自己使用手机，并以调整所有设置的方式去使用它，显然它仍然不如专业相机强大。比如，你可以装一个巨大的、变焦能力极强的镜头，手机做不到。但如果你在正常的拍摄范围内，如果你真的花时间学习一个复杂的手机参数应用，并弄懂所有设置，也许它们是一样的。但人们并没有意识到这一点。这真是一件非常有趣的事情，我之前没花
lot of time thinking about, but I've recently been re-engaging with it and just thinking through like pictures as physical, like actually when was the last time, I don't know, for me, it's been a really long time, printed a picture out, like sent off to be developed oh yeah printed it or held it in my hand it's an entirely different thing to like hold a picture in your hand and like look at it it's crazy remember the last time i held you know a picture one of my own pictures dude it's been i probably haven't had a picture developed until recently i went on a trip and took a family portrait and had it printed for um for my family you know i like a large i was like the first time in probably five six seven years i'd had like a picture become a physical set of atoms okay so i have a couple of questions first of all like
太多时间去思考，但最近我重新开始关注它，思考照片作为实体的意义。说实话，我都不记得上次打印照片是什么时候了，就是那种送去冲印，或者拿在手里。把照片拿在手里看是完全不同的感觉。太疯狂了，我不记得上次拿着自己的照片是什么时候了。我可能直到最近才去冲印照片，我去旅行时拍了一张全家福，并为我的家人打印了出来。这是我五、六、七年来第一次让照片变成一组物理原子。好吧，我有几个问题，首先，
how do you learn how to take pictures like is this something you learned on the internet do you take like a yeah okay got it and i'm by no means claiming to be an artist about it i just it's a interesting process and it's it's really i mean if you're an engineer it look it's not that hard that makes sense so you went on youtube video and it's like okay here's what the different acronyms are and here's you know when shutters one or the other focal length like you can learn these in an hour of, you know, watching YouTube videos and looking on, you know, tutorials. Yeah.
你是怎么学习拍照的？这是你在网上学的吗？你看了什么……哦，明白了。我绝不是自称艺术家，我只是觉得这是一个有趣的过程。如果你是工程师，这并不难。这就说得通了。所以你看了 YouTube 视频，上面写着各种缩写是什么意思，快门、焦距之类的。你可以在一小时内通过看 YouTube 视频和教程学会这些。
Okay. My second question is like, when you're doing something like printing a portrait, have you tried any of these like super scale algorithms where like they'll like increase the DPI of your photo using AI? And did you need anything like that? So I did recently, I had a picture where I needed to zoom
好的。我的第二个问题是，当你打印肖像照时，你有没有尝试过那些超分辨率算法，就是用 AI 增加照片的 DPI？你需要用到那种东西吗？我最近确实用过，有一张照片我需要放大
in a little bit more and I actually did use, which I think I could have done it on my phone too, but I happened to have used my large camera for it. I have a Sony mirrorless camera and it has a bunch of extra resolution. So I zoomed in and it was really noisy because, you know, when you blow a picture up, it's noisy. So I actually didn didn't do super scaling i didn't really need more resolution but i did run one of the ai like denoise of visor denoise of fires um and it did actually like i don't want to say creepy because it didn't put more detail that than was there but it did a really good job like it was suitable it went from like this is blurry and you can see what's happening to like you know it was a picture an event for one of my kids and so it was you know like them doing something up on a stage and so it was far and it was dark it was very
多一点，我其实用了我的大相机。我有一台索尼无反相机，它有额外的分辨率。所以我放大了，但噪点很多，因为当你放大照片时，它会有噪点。我其实没有做超分辨率，我不需要更多分辨率，但我确实运行了一个 AI 降噪器。我不想说它很诡异，因为它并没有凭空增加细节，但它做得非常好。它把原本模糊、看不清发生了什么的照片，变成了一张清晰的照片。那是我孩子的一次活动，他们在舞台上表演，距离很远，光线很暗，非常
noisy afterwards i was able to send it to people and no one realized this was like a tiny corner of a picture that i took because you know wow it's amazing so it's amazing um i recently used the thing where um you you select an area. Basically, my wife had this photo and there were people in the background. It was at the beach. And unfortunately, there was a woman in the background bending over. And so it was just like the most embarrassing shot of this poor stranger in our family photo. And so, yeah yeah there's this
噪点很多。事后我把它发给别人，没人意识到这是我拍的照片的一小部分，因为……哇，太神奇了。确实很神奇。我最近用了一个功能，就是你选择一个区域。基本上，我妻子有张照片，背景里有人。那是在海滩上，不幸的是，背景里有个女人在弯腰。那简直是我们全家福里最尴尬的镜头。所以，是的，有这个
tool you just lasso that part of the image press a button and it in paints it and i was also pretty surprised um you know you know when you see examples you're obviously seeing the best of something or you know someone's at least tried multiple times and they're showing like when you read a research paper they're showing you you know something that they're really proud of and so i was a little skeptical going in but it was great i mean it even drew like a bird i was like wow it's like it had a ton of creativity um and uh yeah it's just shocking where that industry i think but i think that's is from. But I think that's a, to be clear, I think that's a relatively recent development. I think that even,
工具，你只需要套索选中图像的那部分，按一个按钮，它就会进行修复（Inpainting）。我也很惊讶。你知道，当你看到示例时，你看到的显然是最好的结果，或者至少是尝试了多次后的结果。当你阅读研究论文时，他们展示的是他们真正引以为傲的东西。所以我一开始有点怀疑，但效果太棒了。它甚至画出了一只鸟，我当时想，哇，它竟然有这么强的创造力。而且，是的，这个行业的发展速度令人震惊。但我认为，这只是一个相对近期的发展。我认为即使是，
I believe I've seen some press release from Google has been doing some of that, that they are offering that in their Google photo service and stuff too. But I know Photoshop or Lightroom added some of the things you're talking about. But I think it's been like a two year kind of recent development.
我相信我见过谷歌的一些新闻稿，说他们正在他们的谷歌相册服务中提供类似的功能。我知道 Photoshop 或 Lightroom 也添加了你说的这些功能。但我认为这大概是近两年的发展。
If you had tried this five years ago and you'd circled it, it would have done some sort of like color averaging, blur, texture stamping kind of thing versus it wouldn't have. Like if you had a wave at a diagonal, it would have like cut a piece of a wave and put up a nut, but it wouldn't have lined up quite right. It would have left a thing. And it's always been possible for people to go in and do it. It just would have taken enormous amounts of skill and time.
如果你五年前尝试这个，你圈出它，它只会做一些颜色平均、模糊、纹理覆盖之类的处理，而不是真正的修复。比如如果你有一道对角线的波浪，它会切下一块波浪贴上去，但衔接得并不好。它会留下痕迹。人们一直都有可能去手动处理，但这需要极高的技巧和时间。
Now you just, like I said, you just draw a loop around it, tell it you want it, you know, removed and it will, you know, hypothesize about what was there based on what was in the input.
现在你只需要像我说的，画一个圈，告诉它你想要移除它，它就会根据输入的内容推测那里原本应该有什么。
Yeah. I mean, it basically drew an even larger behind, which is exactly what I wanted. That word has become ambiguous in this circumstance because you did want you did want behind what was behind the person that's exactly exactly all right we're degenerating now we better get on to don't be like where's the programming talk oh god uh all right news and links uh let's see patrick you're first uh okay so this one is an article on the blog by i should have looked at but the blog's name is
是的。它基本上画出了一个更大的背景，这正是我想要的。“Behind”这个词在这种情况下变得模棱两可了，因为你确实想要“背后”的东西，也就是那个人身后的东西。没错，没错。好了，我们现在跑题了，还是回到正题吧。别说“编程话题去哪了”。天哪，好吧。新闻和链接，让我们看看，Patrick，你先来。好的，这是一篇博客文章，作者名字叫
robert heaton so i'm gonna go that that's the author's name called pie sky wi-fi um and they don't give actually uh as far as i could tell in the blog post they didn't give a ton of specifics about what they were doing um but this story is so funny but i wanted to use it as as per usual to like talk about kind of this there There's actually something really serious here. And what this person did is they kind of have a story. I believe it's probably apocryphal, but, you know, they have this story about they were flying in an airplane and they wanted to use the internet, but, you know, it charges you some amount of money that always feels like a little bit too expensive, but maybe.
Robert Heaton，我应该查一下的，但博客名字叫“Pie Sky Wi-Fi”。他们在博客文章中并没有给出太多关于他们具体在做什么的细节，但这个故事太有趣了。我通常会用它来谈论这个……其实这里面有一些非常严肃的东西。这个人讲了一个故事，我相信这可能是杜撰的，但他们讲的是他们在飞机上想用互联网，但费用总是感觉太贵了。
And so they needed to do this work, they were going to go, but then they realized they basically could go into their account on the website of the company of the plane. And that was not considered like accessing the internet. So they could, you know, go onto the company's website, check flight times, go to their frequent flyer mile account, that kind of stuff. Then they realized within the frequent flyer mile um there were a couple of their account settings that they could edit things like their name or you know you could imagine like your address and then they had the broad idea of wait a minute i could just start editing these fields and if i ran a program back home i could you know basically start parlaying information by you know think like base 64
他们需要工作，但后来他们意识到他们基本上可以登录飞机公司网站上的账户。这不被视为“访问互联网”。所以他们可以查看航班时间、访问常旅客里程账户之类的。然后他们意识到在常旅客里程账户里，有一些账户设置可以编辑，比如名字，或者你可以想象是地址。于是他们产生了一个大胆的想法：等等，我可以开始编辑这些字段。如果我在家里运行一个程序，我可以开始通过……比如 Base64
encoding there's they use a different scheme but you know i could fill out one field as like a request for a website and have a server back home that could chunk up the website and put it into a different field that i could then read and we could basically pass information at this super low rate right you imagine wait let me let me repeat this and see if i understand so the idea idea is, you know, you can't get on the internet without paying whatever, some nominal fee. But you can do for free is like, you know, in Delta or whatever, you can watch movies. There's like websites they do give you for free. And you're saying one of the free websites is one where you can update, let's say your first and last name on the Delta account.
编码来传递信息。他们用了不同的方案，但你可以把一个字段填成对某个网站的请求，然后在家里有一个服务器，把网站内容分块，放进另一个字段，我再读取它。我们基本上可以以这种超低速率传递信息。等等，让我重复一遍，看看我是否理解了。所以想法是，你不能在不支付费用的情况下上网。但你可以免费做的是，比如在达美航空上，你可以看电影。他们确实提供了一些免费网站。你说其中一个免费网站是可以更新你的达美账户名，比如名字和姓氏。
And so you're saying this person made his first name like google.com and then his last name is like the google.com website. Like another server is also editing the name. Yeah, like imagine it took the whole Google website and coded it in Base64 and put it in his last name. That would, of course, make it really easy. There are, of course, character limits. so you also need to chunk it up which means you need a protocol which means you're probably not doing it by hand so you know how to script and then a proxy sitting on top of
所以你是说这个人把他的名字改成了 google.com，然后姓氏是 google.com 的网站内容？就像另一个服务器也在编辑名字一样。是的，想象一下它把整个谷歌网站用 Base64 编码，放进他的姓氏里。那当然会让事情变得很容易。当然有字符限制，所以你需要分块，这意味着你需要一个协议，这意味着你可能不是手动完成的，所以你知道怎么写脚本，然后在脚本之上加一个代理。
the script um horrible idea uh very likely if they figure out what you're doing you could you know easily it's like tied to your account right you know they anyways not not a good idea i would not definitely not recommend don't try at home a hundred different reasons um but the so two things so the blog article is super useful because it goes into this that if you sort of the beauty of how we have the internet today is it's all these layers right and we tend to forget about them you might learn them in school but um you know all the layers and there? And we tend to forget about them. You might learn them in school, but, you know, all the layers and there's our transport layer and then application layer.
糟糕的主意。如果他们发现你在做什么，很容易就会封掉你的账户。总之，这不是个好主意，我绝对不推荐，不要在家里尝试，有一百个理由。但有两点，这篇博客文章非常有用，因为它深入探讨了这一点：如果你理解我们今天互联网的美妙之处，那就是它所有的层级。我们往往会忘记它们，你可能在学校学过，但所有的层级，传输层，然后是应用层。
And, but this is the beauty of it is like, if he can find a way to pass bytes reliably, you know, or even unreliably, but pass bytes from the airplane to a computer and from the computer back through some protocol, no matter how slow, no matter how bad the data rate is, you can basically wrap that up. And then everything above it just doesn't care. You know, it may be slow, like you go to google.com and you wait 20
这就是它的美妙之处。如果他能找到一种可靠地传递字节的方法，或者即使是不可靠的，但能从飞机向计算机传递字节，再从计算机通过某种协议传回，无论多慢，无论数据速率多差，你基本上都可以封装它。然后上面的所有层都不关心。它可能很慢，比如你访问 google.com，要等 20
minutes before it loads, but it doesn't matter. Like it'll work, you know? And so he, this sort of thing. So one, that's an interesting discussion, a very weird way to get into that discussion about the internet and the protocols behind it and the kind of specifics that was going on. But this is a broader thing is that, to be honest, I've been in this boat before where I did development on microcontrollers or something else really small.
分钟才能加载，但这没关系，它能工作。所以这是一个有趣的讨论，以一种非常奇怪的方式进入了关于互联网和背后协议的讨论。但这是一个更广泛的问题，老实说，我以前也遇到过这种情况，我在微控制器或其他非常小的设备上进行开发。
They didn't have even maybe a serial port that we could use in a way that would work. And if you can find a way to turn something on and off, we were turning a LED, blinking an LED. If you can do it and you have a way to sense it, you can establish a communications protocol. And so we had a thing where we would do a run, we would store up a bunch of data, and then the thing would go into a mode where it would basically blink out ones and zeros with dashes and dots like the telegraph and we had a little like photo cell
它们甚至可能没有我们可以使用的串口。如果你能找到一种方法来开启和关闭某些东西，比如我们曾通过闪烁 LED 灯。如果你能做到这一点，并且有办法感知它，你就可以建立一个通信协议。所以我们有一个方案，我们会运行一段程序，存储大量数据，然后设备进入一种模式，基本上用摩尔斯电码（点和划）闪烁出 0 和 1，我们有一个小的光敏电阻
that would record it and then we would decode the zeros and ones and we would get out the log messages um and sometimes i think we get into this day where we kind of forget about these things that not that long ago you know we were using telephones with audio sound to transmit the internet through, you know, like this is, this is the way it was. Um, but it actually still true today. And there are times if you're going to do, I would call those things kind of hacker things, um, where you're trying to get something out where you don't have full access or not always, definitely not in an illegal way, but just in a sort of surreptitious way. It's just definitely a very interesting thought experiment to kind of challenge yourself instead of just paying the definitely much easier, you know, whatever, $10, $8 to use the internet. Instead, you do
来记录它，然后我们解码这些 0 和 1，就能得到日志信息。有时我觉得我们现在忘记了这些事情，不久前我们还在用音频电话通过声音传输互联网。但这在今天仍然适用。如果你要进行一些我称之为“黑客行为”的事情，试图在没有完全访问权限的情况下获取某些东西，当然不是以非法方式，而是以一种隐蔽的方式。这绝对是一个非常有趣的思维实验，挑战自己，而不是仅仅支付那 10 美元或 8 美元去使用互联网。相反，你做了一个
a horrible end around. But the point isn't the point. The point isn't like not paying for internet and getting this really slow thing the idea is being creative and using the tools that are given to you yeah it's only one thing that just from a from a i guess like artistic uh standpoint i really love the way that this person wrote kind of in the first person and uh kind of like toggled between telling a story and then you know going into some technical details I feel like it's really well done I love it ends with I scrolled around the HTML and reflected that this had been the most and least productive flight of my life yeah there's there's of course a problem there where if you you kind of need to fly twice because
糟糕的绕路。但重点不是不付钱上网，而是发挥创造力，利用给你的工具。是的，从艺术的角度来看，我真的很喜欢这个人用第一人称写作的方式，在讲故事和深入技术细节之间切换。我觉得写得非常好，我喜欢它结尾写道：“我滚动浏览着 HTML，反思着这曾是我一生中最有成效也是最没成效的飞行。”是的，这里当然有个问题，你需要飞两次，因为
the first time you kind of discover this but you unless you pay for the internet you can't actually access your computer back home or set something up on the other end so that's true yeah you have to build it and pay for that yeah that's totally right but now he has a source code available so so anyone who wants to get banned yeah that's right um all right my my new story first new story is this video making anime character uh sorry animated characters with ai art um i thought this was so cool i stumbled upon this because um i typed this in to Google expecting to see a research paper on how to do animations. We have, everyone knows about DALI and stable diffusion, these things where you type in, you know, a horse eating hot dogs on the moon and it'll like render that photo, right?
第一次你发现了这个，但除非你付钱上网，否则你无法真正访问家里的电脑或在另一端设置好东西。所以这是真的，你必须构建它并为此付费。但现在他有源代码了，所以任何想被封号的人都可以……是的，没错。好了，我的下一个新闻故事是这个视频：用 AI 艺术制作动画角色。我觉得这太酷了，我偶然发现这个是因为我输入谷歌搜索，希望能看到关于如何制作动画的研究论文。我们都知道 DALL-E 和 Stable Diffusion，这些你可以输入“一匹马在月球上吃热狗”，它就会渲染出那张照片的东西，对吧？
But there's nothing, and there are things for video as well right but you don't have is something where it's like you know a a 2d you know rig of a horse uh and and what you end up with is this like this marionette puppet right that you can animate um and so i just thought this is like an interesting void here like no one's built like a text to animation um and searching for that i found this video which i thought was just amazing this is basically uh somebody who's they're heavily promoting adobe products although they're not it's not an official adobe video um but what this person does is they start with a text to image and i think they put like a lion wearing a suit or something like that a bipedal line wearing a suit and so you get this
但没有那种东西，虽然也有视频生成工具，但你没有的是那种……比如一个 2D 的马的骨架，你最终得到的是一个可以动画化的木偶。我觉得这是一个有趣的空白，没有人做过“文本转动画”。搜索这个时，我发现了这个视频，我觉得太棒了。这基本上是一个人在大力推广 Adobe 产品，虽然这不是官方的 Adobe 视频。但他从文本转图像开始，我想他输入的是“一只穿西装的狮子”之类的，一只双足行走的狮子。所以你得到了这个
this lion uh standing on two legs uh you know it's pretty human like figure but definitely a lion head uh wearing a suit and then this whole jungle uh background um and so he goes through like he deletes the background but it's you know it's a it's a complex high frequency background it's not like it's on a white sheet or something so so he shows how you can use ai to like detect the background in a sophisticated way deletes the background and then the lion you know because it's a photo one of the hands of the lion is covering his like midsection so again using like lasso tools but they're like intelligent like it's kind of like snapping you to like the semantic segment right he like pulls the arm off and then now you have this like
狮子，双腿站立，人形身材，但绝对是狮子头，穿着西装，背景是整个丛林。他演示了如何删除背景，但这是一个复杂的、高频的背景，不是那种白布背景。所以他展示了如何使用 AI 以复杂的方式检测背景，删除背景。然后狮子，因为它是照片，狮子的一只手遮住了腹部。所以再次使用套索工具，但它们是智能的，就像语义分割一样。他把手臂拉开，现在角色躯干上就有一个
hand arm shape void in the in the torso of the character so he uses the ai in painting and it draws like a pocket of the jeans that was missing you know and all that um and now he has this arm that's kind of bent so he unbends it using some other tools. And basically within about 15 minutes, he goes from this image that was generated by an AI like symbiosis of, you know, AI and, uh, you know, real skilled, uh,
手臂形状的空洞。所以他使用 AI 修复（Inpainting），它画出了缺失的牛仔裤口袋之类的。现在他有了一只弯曲的手臂，他用其他工具把它拉直。基本上在 15 分钟内，他从一个由 AI 生成的图像，变成了 AI 与真正熟练的
artisan, uh, work on the computer. So, uh, definitely worth about 10, 15 minutes. I mean,
工匠在计算机上的协作成果。所以，绝对值得花 10 到 15 分钟看看。我的意思是，
if you're not super into it, you can kind of skip ahead, skip to different parts. Uh, but I was just enthralled with, uh, with, with this person's ability and,
如果你不是特别感兴趣，你可以跳过，直接看不同部分。但我被这个人的能力所吸引，
and all the different AI tools that uh some of which i didn't even know existed i've seen a few examples like like this where you you mentioned it a person with skill just becomes like much more powerful having access to tools and being willing to have a creative approach to the problem. So, you know, being willing to say, it doesn't matter that I have 100 years or whatever, that's too many, 20 years of experience drawing this scene from scratch. I'm going to see if there's a, I'll call it a better way, but also being willing to leverage the fact that I am still an artist. I still know how to rig a 2d you know animated character is something for instance i wouldn't know how to do but they did um and so yeah i think
以及所有那些我甚至不知道存在的 AI 工具。我见过一些这样的例子，你提到的，一个有技能的人在拥有这些工具并愿意采取创造性方法解决问题时，会变得强大得多。所以，愿意说“我不需要花 100 年，或者 20 年经验从零开始画这个场景”。我会看看是否有更好的方法，同时也愿意利用我仍然是一名艺术家这一事实。我仍然知道如何给 2D 动画角色绑定骨骼，这是我不会做但他们会做的。所以，是的，我认为
this is one of those i'm curious to see what will happen like maybe ai will just leap ahead and be able to do it from scratch but much more likely in the midterm we're going to see willing people able to just scale their productivity unbelievably using approaches that are kind of blended or hybrid like this. And we don't really have a term to call it. Like it's not really AI art anymore, but right. Right. That way. Yeah, that's right. I have a friend who maybe AI assisted art or something. I have a friend who's in the games industry and he goes to a lot of these conventions and he said last year you know if you went to gdc one of these conventions and you gave
这是一个我很好奇会发生什么的事情。也许 AI 会突飞猛进，能够从零开始完成，但更有可能的是，在中期内，我们将看到人们能够通过这种混合或融合的方法，不可思议地扩展他们的生产力。我们还没有一个术语来称呼它。它不再仅仅是 AI 艺术了，但……是的，没错。我有一个朋友在游戏行业，他参加了很多会议。他说去年如果你去 GDC 这样的会议，如果你做了一个
a talk on ai art um someone would just like stab you in the back uh in the heart and uh drag you away metaphorically speaking like the audience would just destroy you. Throw rotten tomatoes at you, yeah. Yeah, there would be no trace of you left on planet Earth. But this year, he went to I don't remember where. I saw it at GDC, but he just got back from another conference. And he said, it's just everywhere now. He said, it's kind of like he described it as COVID, where people tried to contain it and then now it's just everywhere um so it's like uh there's whole companies with stands and booths
关于 AI 艺术的演讲，有人会从背后捅你一刀，把你拖走。比喻来说，观众会摧毁你。扔烂番茄之类的。是的，地球上不会留下你的痕迹。但今年，他去了……我不记得在哪里了，我在 GDC 上看到的，但他刚从另一个会议回来。他说，现在到处都是。他形容这就像新冠疫情，人们试图控制它，但现在它无处不在。所以，有整个公司带着展位
like you know talking about their ai tools and people are giving talks on it and there's just there's just no going back from that now wild times yeah all right my next article i'll keep this short um the title is the real 10x developer makes their whole team better and this is on the stack overflow blog um i i just generally wanted to take a moment on 10x engineers um this blog post was it's pretty short and mostly just talking about uh the there's a sort of mythical 10x developer that that floats around in various forms and people debate you know are there really people 10x more productive uh and the answer is in certain contexts probably or even more um sometimes people call them sort of rock star engineers or rock star developers
谈论他们的 AI 工具，人们在做相关演讲，现在已经回不去了。疯狂的时代。好了，我的下一篇文章，我会简短一点。标题是《真正的 10 倍开发者让整个团队变得更好》，这是在 Stack Overflow 博客上。我只是想花点时间谈谈“10 倍工程师”。这篇博客文章很短，主要是在谈论那个在各种形式中流传的“神话般的 10 倍开发者”，人们争论是否真的有比别人高效 10 倍的人。答案是，在某些背景下，可能甚至更多。有时人们称他们为“摇滚明星工程师”或“摇滚明星开发者”。
and the blog is trying to make the point that uh through a specific process they were sort of rockstar engineers or rockstar developers. And the blog is trying to make the point that through a specific process, they were sort of saying, you know, communities of practice, I've heard them called centers of excellence, or people gathering together. And the real way to be effective is to basically help the team around you. And you really can 10x, you know, an experience or the ability of your team to its total output if you can really communicate knit together encourage good practices mentor like these kinds of things and it really does resonate with me this is something that has become i don't know like a pet peeve is exactly the right word but people you know i want to hire someone just like super
博客试图表达的观点是，通过一个特定的过程，他们……博客试图表达的观点是，通过一个特定的过程，他们是在说“实践社区”，我听过他们被称为“卓越中心”，或者人们聚集在一起。真正有效的方法是基本上帮助你周围的团队。如果你能真正沟通、凝聚、鼓励良好的实践、指导他人，你真的可以让团队的产出提升 10 倍。这确实引起了我的共鸣。这已经成为……我不知道，“眼中钉”这个词是否准确，但人们想要雇佣那种“超级聪明”的人，就是房间里最聪明的人。
super smart like just the smartest person in the room and And it's maybe, I mean, when I look at them or think about composing teams that are working with such people, it's like, but how do they communicate? How do they work with others? If they're super amazing in certain circumstances, it may be useful, but far more useful as a person that can, you know, work well with others, help, you know, make, you know, better than the, some of the pieces, I guess, is the, is the kind of way of saying that. And it sounds goofy, but I really have run across people who are like that. They tend to be very giving. So they're not super, you know, self-focused, you know, they're always trying to look around and say, how can they help people? How can they improve the stack? How can they make tooling better? And I really do think there's the ability to just have a very outsized return
当我看着他们或考虑组建与这样的人一起工作的团队时，我会想：但他们如何沟通？他们如何与他人合作？如果他们在某些情况下超级厉害，那可能有用，但更有用的是一个能与他人良好合作、帮助团队实现“整体大于部分之和”的人。这听起来很傻，但我确实遇到过这样的人。他们往往非常慷慨。他们不是那种以自我为中心的人，他们总是环顾四周，问：我能如何帮助别人？我能如何改进技术栈？我能如何让工具变得更好？我真的认为，如果考虑到一个人帮助他人的能力，他确实能产生巨大的回报。
on, you know, a single person, if you consider it across their ability to help others. And in some ways, regardless of whether there are people who can be, you know, 10 times more effective code output, I think that the ability to knit together a team is sort of far more useful. And so when people think about their own careers, this is much less talked about, how to help others, how to make your team better. And even on this podcast somewhat, it's like specific skills you can learn, ways to make your own problem solving better and more improved. And those things are important, but also thinking through how are you a good team player? And it's a much more subtle and less easy to talk about problem. Yeah, I think that's fair. Totally.
无论是否真的有人能实现 10 倍的代码产出，我认为凝聚团队的能力要有用得多。所以当人们思考自己的职业生涯时，这方面谈论得很少：如何帮助他人，如何让你的团队变得更好。即使在这个播客上，我们谈论的也是你可以学习的具体技能，让自己的问题解决能力变得更好。这些很重要，但也要思考你如何成为一个好的团队成员。这是一个更微妙、更难谈论的问题。是的，我认为这很公平。完全同意。
You know, yeah, I've thought about this a lot, the 10x engineer thing. I mean, one thing that comes to mind is like it's really kind of a bit of a faulty premise right because if a person is a 10x engineer then it's it really just becomes about saving money right like like if a person is doing 10 times as much work then there's nine there's that's nine people you don't have to hire and it just becomes this big money game like cisco hires 10 engineers facebook hires one 10x engineer and they both end up exactly the same and i feel like it's kind of a false premise i i think that uh i think you're right i think there's there's several different things that you can combine with your engineering skill that that are very like in high
你知道，我思考过很多关于 10 倍工程师的事情。我想到的第一点是，这其实是一个错误的命题。因为如果一个人是 10 倍工程师，那真的就变成了省钱的问题。如果一个人做了 10 倍的工作，那就意味着有 9 个人你不需要雇佣了。这变成了一个巨大的金钱游戏。思科雇佣 10 个工程师，Facebook 雇佣 1 个 10 倍工程师，结果是一样的。我觉得这是一个错误的命题。我认为你是对的，我认为有几种不同的东西可以与你的工程技能结合，这些技能在市场上需求很高，但供应很少。
demand and low supply so i think you know engineers that are really talented and can also kind of coordinate and influence a team uh is is that's a really hard combination to find and those people i think do really well i think i think engineers that are extremely multi-disciplinary and can build a prototype by themselves um that is also kind of rare like someone who is you know they talk about the mythical like full stack engineer right but but really it's like you know you might be a front-end person but you know maybe you have to train this ai because you have this idea that involves the latest ai and front-end and so to be able the ability to just go in and learn whatever it takes to build like a 10 solution you know a
所以我认为，非常有才华且能协调和影响团队的工程师，这是一个很难找到的组合，这些人我认为做得非常好。我认为那些极其多学科、能独自构建原型的工程师，也是很罕见的。就像他们谈论神话般的“全栈工程师”，但实际上，你可能是一个前端人员，但也许你需要训练这个 AI，因为你有一个涉及最新 AI 和前端的想法。所以，能够去学习构建一个 10 倍解决方案所需的一切，你知道，一个……
minimum viable product i think that's a rare skill A lot of people are stuck kind of in their niche. And when you can combine those two, it's like, okay, here's someone who can build prototypes that have, you know, something visual could be internal, doesn't have to be perfect, but some kind of visual component and some interesting kind of backend component, and then like motivate that prototype so that a team can work with them to take that prototype into something that creates value. You know, those, when you start like finding the intersection of these very rare skills, that's when you start to get someone who is truly mythic. Um, but yeah, it's, uh, I'm totally with you i think you know the idea that like you have this person who like uh you know can't is is non-verbal but like sits in your basement and writes 10x as much
最小可行性产品，我认为这是一种稀缺技能。很多人被困在自己的小圈子里。当你能将这两者结合起来时，就像是，好吧，这里有一个人可以构建原型，你知道，有一些视觉效果，可以是内部的，不需要完美，但要有某种视觉组件和一些有趣的后端组件，然后推动这个原型，让团队可以与他们合作，将原型转化为创造价值的东西。你知道，当你开始找到这些非常稀缺技能的交集时，你就会得到一个真正神话般的人。嗯，但是是的，我完全同意你的观点，我认为你知道那种想法，就是你有这样一个人，他，你知道，不能，是，是非语言的，但坐在地下室里，写出的代码是别人的10倍
code as other people like that never really made sense to me either um so it's good that people that um all right so okay patrick i want you to watch this video um i'm gonna i'm gonna read the title while patrick watches it and gives us his his live reaction it's called the beauty and challenges of ai generated artistic gymnastics oh dear oh oh this is will smith eats spaghetti that's right it's it's that but it's it's with oh oh which makes it even worse it's like better than that it's like version two for sure like it's much better than that but it's so much weird okay i just watched a gymnastic shaped thing fall through the floor okay so but i don't this is nightmare fuel my friend why have you done this to me so like at some point it's like wait but it's clearly obvious what it is like you can see legs and arms and gymnastics
像其他人一样，这对我来说也从来没有意义，嗯，所以人们这样做是好事，嗯，好吧，帕特里克，我想让你看这个视频，嗯，我要，我要读标题，同时帕特里克观看它并给我们他的实时反应，它叫《人工智能生成的艺术体操的美丽与挑战》，哦天哪，哦，哦，这是威尔·史密斯吃意大利面，没错，就是那个，但它是，它是和，哦，哦，这让它变得更糟了，它比那个更好，肯定是第二版，因为它比那个好得多，但它太奇怪了，好吧，我刚刚看到一个体操形状的东西掉进了地板，好吧，所以我不知道，这是噩梦般的燃料，我的朋友，你为什么要对我做这种事，所以，在某种程度上，就像，等等，但很明显它是什么，你可以看到腿和手臂和体操
leotards i don't know what you call them but none of like if you pause any one of these frames and just showed it to someone they would not it would just be bad ai yeah the difference i think what makes this so much like next level beyond the will smith video is is the quality is so good you know in sense of like you know when you do see somebody's face um it looks good um it's just the the interplay there's just so much i don't know how to describe everyone needs to take a moment go to our show notes click the link um and watch this. It's only a minute, but it's... How does this only have 31,000 views? Like, did this get ripped off of like TikTok or something?
紧身衣，我不知道你怎么称呼它们，但如果暂停这些帧中的任何一帧并展示给别人看，他们不会，这只会是糟糕的人工智能，是的，我认为这比威尔·史密斯视频更上一层楼的区别在于质量太好了，你知道，在某种意义上，当你看到某人的脸时，嗯，它看起来不错，嗯，只是相互作用，有太多，我不知道怎么描述，每个人都需要花点时间，去我们的节目笔记，点击链接，嗯，观看这个。只有一分钟，但它是……为什么这只有31,000次观看？就像，这是从TikTok之类的东西上扒下来的吗？
Oh, here, from Instagram. I see. It looks like... Oh, no, I can't tell. Oh, yeah, maybe... I found this in, I think, a machine learning Reddit or something. I'm not sure exactly where I found it. But yeah, let me see if we
哦，在这里，来自Instagram。我明白了。看起来像……哦，不，我看不出来。哦，是的，也许……我是在，我想，一个机器学习Reddit或类似的地方找到这个的。我不确定具体是在哪里找到的。但是是的，让我看看我们
could describe this okay so basically what this is is an ai for folks who who aren't gonna watch a video or listening in in their car or something it's a it's a ai generated video of gymnastics so imagine you know the the parallel bars uh the uh what is it called when the balance so more specifically if you ever watch it like during the olympics it uh what is it called when the balance so more specifically if you ever watch it like during the olympics it's like that exact setup so the stadium right you know all like the there's like judges on the side so it's like a very conventional gymnastics meet or competition or whatever you call it yeah and then there's like gymnasts on a balance beam and you'll see a frame where the person is standing like at the start of their routine then they begin to do their routine except instead of bending down and doing
能不能描述一下，好吧，所以基本上这就是一个人工智能，对于那些不打算看视频或在车里听的人，或者类似的东西，这是一个人工智能生成的体操视频，所以想象一下，你知道，双杠，嗯，嗯，当平衡木时叫什么，所以更具体地说，如果你在奥运会期间看过它，它，嗯，当平衡木时叫什么，所以更具体地说，如果你在奥运会期间看过它，就像那个确切的设置，所以体育场，对吧，你知道，所有的，就像，那边有裁判，所以就像一个非常传统的体操比赛或竞赛，或者你叫它什么，是的，然后平衡木上有体操运动员，你会看到一个人站在他们动作开始时的画面，然后他们开始做他们的动作，除了不是弯腰做
a handstand with their legs flipping up in the air their head folds into their stomach and they go into a gymnastic shaped blob that then falls through the floor and separates into two pieces and but the fans are in the background like they're still bleachers the scene has coherence they look billboarded or something it's still bleachers the scene has coherence they look billboarded or something it's very weird but the scene has coherence it's just like it clearly like yeah it doesn't understand whatever it understands about humans the gymnastics are breaking those assumptions right right and and you know there's this contrast between the gymnast who is like, you know, just just morphing between all these like aberrations. I mean, there's one where it's just like two sets of legs connected to each other that are flipping over over each other.
一个倒立，双腿向上翻转，他们的头折叠进胃里，他们变成了一个体操形状的斑点，然后掉进地板，分成两块，但是背景里的粉丝，就像他们还在看台上，场景有连贯性，他们看起来像广告牌或什么的，它仍然是看台，场景有连贯性，他们看起来像广告牌或什么的，这非常奇怪，但场景有连贯性，它只是像，很明显，是的，它不理解它对人类理解的任何东西，体操正在打破这些假设，对，对，而且你知道，体操运动员之间有这种对比，他就像，你知道，只是在所有这些像畸变的东西之间变形。我的意思是，有一个地方就像两组腿连接在一起，互相翻转。
But there's this contrast between that and the people, you know, there's gymnasts who are preparing or there's judges. And those people, because they have pretty know emotional frequency if they're pretty normal uh but there's this person in the middle who's just completely you know like going through some crazy emotions yeah and the equipment although it bends weird like tends to also be well rendered um but right and you see people in the background yeah like oscillate like there's a judge in a suit and then it transitions to a person in a white shirt sitting at a score table like there yeah the more you watch this the weirder i gotta stop watching this dude all right i'm out yeah i mean it's one of these things you can just every time you see something different
但是这和人们之间有这种对比，你知道，有正在准备的体操运动员，或者有裁判。而那些人，因为他们有相当的情感频率，如果他们相当正常，嗯，但中间有个人，他只是完全，你知道，经历着一些疯狂的情绪，是的，设备虽然弯曲得很奇怪，但往往也渲染得很好，嗯，但是对，你在背景中看到人们，是的，像振荡，就像一个穿西装的裁判，然后它过渡到一个坐在记分台上的穿白衬衫的人，那里，是的，你看得越多，越奇怪，我得停止看这个了，伙计，好吧，我退出了，是的，我的意思是，这是你可以每次看到不同东西的事情之一
um but yeah i think uh it's a okay actually i remember my point okay so is it uncanny valley related because that's that's what i'm getting the vibes of but yeah oh it's definitely got uncanny valley vibes my point is i'm seeing a critical flaw i saw it in 2012 when we did the alex debt stuff um and then you know i saw it again with self-driving cars, also around 2012. And then I'm seeing it again, where people who aren't in the AI field, especially investors, a lot of people with a lot of influence who are generally really smart people who are counted on on their expertise, they fail to see that AI is this extremely multidisciplinary field. and being good in one area doesn't mean you're good in all of them so so if you have superhuman uh image detection that doesn't mean
嗯，但是是的，我想，嗯，这是一个，好吧，实际上我记得我的观点，好吧，所以它和恐怖谷有关吗？因为那就是我感觉到的氛围，但是是的，哦，它绝对有恐怖谷的氛围，我的观点是我看到了一个严重的缺陷，我在2012年我们做亚历克斯·德特（Alex Debt）的东西时看到了它，然后你知道，我在2012年左右又看到了它，和自动驾驶汽车一起。然后我又看到了它，那些不在人工智能领域的人，尤其是投资者，很多有很大影响力的人，他们通常是非常聪明的人，依靠他们的专业知识，他们没有看到人工智能是一个极其多学科的领域。在一个领域表现出色并不意味着你在所有领域都表现出色，所以如果你有超人的图像检测能力，那并不意味着
you've reached superhuman ai and and i think probably what we'll see over time is is ai like be less of a of a focus and and and us to like break down ai into more of these subfields right because with self-driving car you know the the detecting of stop signs and pedestrians and these things became superhuman right early on um and and and so people thought oh well you know we're we're days away right but the reality is is the policy like knowing when you can break the rules knowing like okay there's a set of road cones here but that really means that that whole area is off limits like the road cones are kind of telling you this lane is shut down like all of the common sense there we're well behind humans but because we're super human on the image stuff people didn't people kind of translated that and so you know i think we
你已经达到了超人的人工智能，我认为随着时间的推移，我们可能会看到人工智能不再是一个焦点，我们把人工智能分解成更多这些子领域，对吧？因为对于自动驾驶汽车，你知道，检测停车标志和行人以及这些东西在早期就变得超人了，对吧，嗯，所以人们认为，哦，好吧，你知道，我们离那一天只有几天了，对吧，但现实是，政策，就像知道什么时候可以打破规则，知道，好吧，这里有一组路锥，但这真的意味着整个区域都是禁区，就像路锥在告诉你这条车道被关闭了，就像所有的常识一样，我们远远落后于人类，但因为我们在图像方面是超人的，人们没有，人们有点翻译了它，所以你知道，我认为我们
talked about the in painting and and how good it is and everything in the beginning but it's good for you to know that like there's still like entire fields of ai where where um uh we're just massively massively behind and and i think uh this kind of shows that i think you know merging ai with kind of something that's like physically plausible or just having continuity um is something that we don't really know how to do very well yet this one yeah i mean i think there's lots of extensions so gymnastics specifically probably is very difficult because the poses are very uncommon in the training data like the people are to some extent i mean it's super humans, exceptional human, like these people are very elite in a very specific set of skills. So they're doing things that are far outside, like standing on your hands. As an example, if you looked at imagery across human, you know,
谈到了修复（in-painting）以及它在开始时有多好，以及所有这些，但你知道仍然有整个领域的人工智能，嗯，我们只是远远远远落后，我认为这有点显示了这一点，我认为你知道，将人工智能与某种物理上合理的东西合并，或者只是有连续性，是我们还不知道如何做得很好的事情，这个，是的，我的意思是，我认为有很多扩展，所以体操特别可能非常困难，因为姿势在训练数据中非常不常见，就像人们在某种程度上，我的意思是，这是超人，杰出的人类，这些人是一组非常特定技能的精英。所以他们做的事情远远超出了，比如倒立。作为一个例子，如果你观察人类的意象，你知道，
civilization, the amount of people standing on their hand at any given time is super, super low, right? But during a gymnastics gymnastics routine you spend huge amounts of your time like hands down feet up right it's yeah so there's problems with that and then like you said too i think there's all these layers and layers of of nuance and semantics that just yeah it i don't know if it's the same but it it feels similar to when, you know, my software is done and it's like, well, maybe like you never, we are very bad sometimes at identifying the quote unquote hard part, um, or the part that'll take the most time. And so you get people really excited and then you, yeah, kind of see it tip over and fail. But the inpainting example is a good example.
文明，任何时候倒立的人数都非常非常少，对吧？但在体操动作中，你花费大量时间像手向下脚向上，对吧，是的，所以这有问题，然后就像你说的，我认为还有所有这些层层叠叠的细微差别和语义，这只是，是的，我不知道它是否一样，但它感觉类似于，你知道，我的软件完成了，就像，好吧，也许你从来没有，我们有时非常不擅长识别所谓的困难部分，嗯，或者最耗时的部分。所以你让人们非常兴奋，然后你，是的，有点看到它倾覆并失败。但修复的例子是一个很好的例子。
Like you inpaint in this way we're saying and if it fails it's very low risk you just do it again or you're trying a different way right that's very different than i have some security camera and there's a tree in the way and so i'm going to in paint the tree and like use that as like anything could show up there people are going to get confused like it's a very you know risky endeavor like that that's not you would go oh that obviously isn't going to work it's like well maybe i mean yeah that case it seems pretty obvious but to some people you may show them that and they may be thinking like oh it can see through leaves and it's like of the tree and it's like that's not really how it works yeah i'm going to impaint
就像你以我们说的方式修复，如果它失败了，风险很低，你只是再做一次，或者你尝试不同的方式，对吧，这和我有一个安全摄像头，中间有一棵树，所以我打算修复那棵树，并像使用它一样，任何东西都可能出现在那里，人们会感到困惑，这非常，你知道，冒险的努力，就像，那不是，你会说，哦，那显然行不通，就像，好吧，也许，我的意思是，是的，那个案例看起来很明显，但对某些人来说，你可能会向他们展示那个，他们可能会想，哦，它可以看穿叶子，树的，就像，那不是它真正的工作方式，是的，我要修复
my stock portfolio and it sees oh there's this enron sized hole but you probably could find examples where it worked great for whatever reason just by by happenstance or whatever like yeah you inpaint and it predicts the stock trend and then you think you can just inpaint as a way of doing stock trading yeah you know this is a hype cycle i've seen within like my like kind of local community and I'm seeing it now. And they think they can predict the stock market and they do well as long as everyone else is doing well. And then they get completely crushed. I mean, I don't want to wish any future ill will
我的股票投资组合，它看到，哦，有一个安然大小的漏洞，但你可能可以通过偶然或其他原因找到它工作得很好的例子，就像，是的，你修复它，它预测股票趋势，然后你认为你可以只是通过修复作为股票交易的一种方式，是的，你知道，这是一个炒作周期，我在我当地社区看到过，我现在也看到了。他们认为他们可以预测股市，只要其他人做得好，他们就做得好。然后他们被彻底摧毁了。我的意思是，我不想祝愿任何未来有任何恶意
to ill gains to anybody that I know, but I've just seen this so many times now that when someone says, yeah, you know, I'm also doing some algorithmic trading on the side and oh it's like starting to make x amount of money and it's like at some point i don't need to work because i'll just make x and at some point x will become enough and and then there's always some kind of market downturn and almost every time people get hit really really hard yeah i pay a fair amount of attention
给任何我认识的人带来糟糕的收益，但我现在已经看到这种情况太多次了，当有人说，是的，你知道，我也在旁边做一些算法交易，哦，它开始赚取X数量的钱，就像在某个时候我不需要工作，因为我只会赚X，在某个时候X会变得足够，然后总会有某种市场低迷，几乎每次人们都会受到非常非常严重的打击，是的，我相当关注
i mean we talked about on this thing to finances and the stock market and that kind of stuff to be convinced out of what you're saying just go look at the kind of people who work at renaissance technologies and the kind of proven returns that they get and then say can you out compete those folks um if you don't know we don't have time now, but like, yeah, the kinds of people Renaissance Technologies hires for their hedge funds and Jim Simons and like, yeah. Yeah, there's just, yeah.
我的意思是，我们在这个关于财务和股市以及这类事情上谈论过，要被你说服，只要去看看那些在文艺复兴科技公司工作的人，以及他们获得的经过验证的回报，然后说，你能胜过那些人吗？嗯，如果你不知道，我们现在没有时间，但是，是的，文艺复兴科技公司为他们的对冲基金雇佣的那种人，以及吉姆·西蒙斯，等等，是的。是的，只是，是的。
I don't want to go toe-to-toe with the kind of folks that work there. Yeah, I mean, just, okay. So to play devil's advocate, you could argue that there's also a lot of really uninformed people um but i think it's you know it's not it's not the kind of situation where you just have to be better than the average trader i think you have to be a lot better than that to have a guaranteed stable high yield and so just just saying like oh i i know ai and i can use it and be better than like the 50th percentile trader probably isn't enough
我不想和在那里工作的人针锋相对。是的，我的意思是，只是，好吧。为了扮演魔鬼的代言人，你可以争辩说也有很多非常不知情的人，嗯，但我认为你知道，这不是那种你只需要比普通交易者更好的情况，我认为你必须比那好得多才能有保证的稳定高收益，所以只是说，哦，我懂人工智能，我可以使用它，并且比第50百分位的交易者更好，可能还不够
to quit your job for example yeah i would say it a little different is but kind of the same idea is if when you talk to these people and i'm no i'm no expert and i'm not trying to gate you and do whatever you want i don't really i don't really care like yeah it's not financial advice if you lose all your money it's not our fault a lot of the success stories are you know survivorship bias one that's true they were doing this at a very different time you know 40 50 years ago um i i think like you said yeah there's a lot of the meme stocks but if you see the people who go up against on the other side of gme uh the gamestop and how wrecked they get even though
辞掉你的工作，例如，是的，我会说得有点不同，但有点同样的想法是，如果你和这些人交谈，我不是专家，我不是想阻止你，做你想做的任何事，我真的，我真的不在乎，就像，是的，这不是财务建议，如果你赔光了所有的钱，那不是我们的错，很多成功故事都是，你知道，幸存者偏差，这是真的，他们在40、50年前在一个非常不同的时间做这件事，嗯，我认为就像你说的，是的，有很多模因股票，但如果你看到那些在GME另一边的人，GameStop，以及他们受到的破坏，即使
that they're well financed like trading against that you know maybe even now but then the thing is i think a lot of the people i hear saying what you do go to it's like a certain corner of the internet but experts don't hang out there and so you get a lot of other people who are talking about algorithmic trading specifically is a really bad one and Python scripts and things you can share and bots. And people are more than happy to sell shovels to gold miners for technologies and data sources
他们资金充足，就像那样交易，你知道，也许即使是现在，但问题是，我认为我听到很多人说你所做的事情，去，就像互联网的某个角落，但专家不去那里，所以你得到很多其他人谈论算法交易，特别是一个非常糟糕的，Python脚本和你可以分享的东西，以及机器人。人们非常乐意向淘金者出售铲子，以获取技术和数据源
and this kind of stuff. And they're not a legitimate business. I mean, they're just trying to help people. But if you go spend time listening to industry podcasts or people who are sharing a little bit and just the amount of consideration, so not just volatility, but the curve of volatility as you go through the expirations and options and how hedging and the various Greeks and the various inefficiencies or efficiencies of options versus futures.
以及这类东西。他们不是合法的企业。我的意思是，他们只是想帮助人们。但如果你花时间听行业播客或分享一点点的人，仅仅是考虑的程度，所以不仅仅是波动性，而是当你经历到期日和期权时的波动性曲线，以及对冲和各种希腊字母，以及期权与期货的各种低效率或效率。
And when you start talking to most people who are doing the kind of like, oh, I see, you know, up into the right returns, they have to make an argument that that stuff is irrelevant, that it doesn't matter. All that matters is number go up. And that's fine but you probably need to go learn about all those other things and at least say they don't apply or you've considered them and determined them to be irrelevant rather than i didn't even know that was a thing yep yeah exactly um all right we'll go to book of the show. Patrick, you're first. What's your book of the show? All right. Mine is The Three-Body Problem by, oh, okay. We're going to try it. No, no, I don't know. Okay. Zijin Liu. Okay. I can't say it. All right. You can look it up. The Three-Body Problem. This was a book I had read a while ago. I thought I must've talked about it, but I looked it up and I don't think I have. And it is written by a Chinese author,
当你开始和大多数正在做那种，哦，我看到，你知道，向右上方回报的人交谈时，他们必须争辩说那些东西是不相关的，它不重要。所有重要的是数字上涨。这很好，但你可能需要去学习所有那些其他的东西，至少说它们不适用，或者你已经考虑过它们并确定它们是不相关的，而不是我甚至不知道那是什么东西，是的，是的，完全正确，嗯，好吧，我们去节目的书。帕特里克，你先。你的节目书是什么？好吧。我的是《三体》，哦，好吧。我们要试一试。不，不，我不知道。好吧。刘慈欣。好吧。我说不出来。好吧。你可以查一下。《三体》。这是一本我很久以前读过的书。我以为我一定谈论过它，但我查了一下，我不认为我有。它是中国作者写的，
which is super interesting in science fiction, because I feel like it feels very different to a lot of Western science fiction that's written. But it recently got made into a series by Netflix from the people who did Game of Thrones. But if that makes it better or worse for you as your own sort of opinion. But the Three-Body Problem itself is, I think it's a trilogy. I only ever read the first book because I actually didn't love the book. But here, the
这在科幻小说中非常有趣，因为我觉得它感觉与许多西方科幻小说非常不同。但它最近被Netflix改编成了一部剧集，由《权力的游戏》的制作人制作。但如果这让你觉得更好或更糟，作为你自己的某种观点。但《三体》本身是，我认为它是一个三部曲。我只读过第一本书，因为我其实并不喜欢这本书。但在这里，
TV series actually makes it a little bit more palatable, I think, than the book, which was pretty tough to read for me. But definitely an interesting take of, you know, during the Chinese Revolution, someone just basically, like, down on humanity, it's not good, like, there's lots of problems, and ends up communicating with an alien race that, you know, doesn't share that with other people. And then when people find out, there's this whole, like, how is humanity want to relate to the fact that there are aliens coming to earth um and then it sort of plays out from there i read the summary so you may consider that a spoiler but that was all stuff contained in the back of the book so um yeah interesting setup interesting problem um there are all sorts of other like you know semi-nearby people talk about
电视剧实际上让它变得比书更可口一点，我认为，书对我来说读起来相当困难。但绝对是一个有趣的视角，你知道，在中国革命期间，有人基本上，就像，对人类感到失望，它不好，就像，有很多问题，最终与一个外星种族交流，你知道，不与其他人分享这一点。然后当人们发现时，有整个，就像，人类如何想要面对有外星人来到地球的事实，嗯，然后它从那里展开，我读了摘要，所以你可能认为那是剧透，但那都是书后面包含的东西，所以，嗯，是的，有趣的设置，有趣的问题，嗯，还有各种其他像，你知道，半附近的人谈论
um you know if if you kind of believe that earth is on a catastrophic course due to you know global climate change in some way could you really just release tons of fertilizer into the ocean to sequester carbon dioxide by causing a giant algae bloom. And it really is, when you start to look at it, feasible that a very, very, very small group of people could take something that has absolutely catastrophic results for Earth or for humans, kind of like just on their own. That there doesn't need to be a group agreement or a large decision-making body.
嗯，你知道，如果你有点相信地球由于你知道全球气候变化在某种程度上处于灾难性的轨道上，你真的可以释放大量的肥料到海洋中，通过引起巨大的藻类爆发来封存二氧化碳吗？当你开始观察它时，确实是可行的，一个非常非常非常小的人群可以采取一些对地球或人类有绝对灾难性结果的东西，有点像他们自己。不需要群体协议或大型决策机构。
And it's kind of an interesting take. And so definitely recommend it. I just finished the Netflix series series i also thought they did a good job with it so if you're looking for something to watch it's definitely a pretty serious uh show so um just know that going in but yeah oh cool um yeah i i will actually check that out. So on Netflix, is it also called The Three-Body Problem? Yes. Oh, very cool. Yeah, so my book of the show is also a book that I wasn't crazy about. So I guess Patrick and I have something going on. So just breaking the fourth wall here, listeners, Patrick and I, we read a lot. I don't know if we read more than one book every two weeks. I mean, that's pretty hard for at least for me to do.
这是一种有趣的视角。所以绝对推荐它。我刚刚看完了Netflix系列，我也认为他们做得很好，所以如果你正在寻找可以看的东西，它绝对是一部相当严肃的节目，所以，嗯，只是在进入之前知道这一点，但是的，哦酷，嗯，是的，我实际上会去看看。所以，在Netflix上，它也叫《三体》吗？是的。哦，非常酷。是的，所以我的节目书也是一本我不太喜欢的书。所以我猜帕特里克和我有什么事情发生。所以只是打破第四面墙，听众们，帕特里克和我，我们读了很多书。我不知道我们是否每两周读不止一本书。我的意思是，这对我来说至少很难做到。
And so we're going to have to review whatever we're reading. And so it sounds like this week we read some books we're not totally crazy about. I will say that. So my book is the checklist manifesto um i really enjoyed the stories um so this person is a doctor a medical doctor and so a lot of their stories were just really interesting medical situations um there is a lot of medical uh or maybe what's the right word like uh i mean they are like cutting people open and doing all sorts of stuff and there is some detail there so if you're very squeamish obviously there's no pictures or anything but if you're squeamish uh you know think about that before you get the book but um but i thought it was fascinating i mean it's a there's a whole world around
所以我们将不得不回顾我们正在阅读的任何东西。所以听起来这周我们读了一些我们不太喜欢的书。我会说。所以我的书是《清单宣言》，我真的很喜欢这些故事，所以这个人是一名医生，一名医学博士，所以他们的很多故事只是非常有趣的医疗情况，有很多医疗，或者也许什么是正确的词，就像，嗯，我的意思是他们就像切开人们并做各种各样的事情，那里有一些细节，所以如果你非常容易晕血，显然没有图片或任何东西，但如果你容易晕血，嗯，你知道，在你买书之前考虑一下，但是，嗯，但我认为它很迷人，我的意思是，有一个完整的世界围绕着
um patients and complications that can happen and miraculous survival stories, resurrection stories, people who are completely incapacitated and doctors are able to revive them. The point of the book is that you should have checklists and force everyone to use them. And it's like a pretty simple point i mean you know it definitely doesn't need a whole book um the book doesn't you know it kind of motivates through example which is a little strange because it's kind of um you know if you give an example someone can't really argue that like if you're like okay, I added a checklist and then we saved this person's life. The argument against that is what?
嗯，病人和可能发生的并发症，以及奇迹般的生存故事，复活故事，人们完全丧失能力，医生能够复活他们。这本书的重点是你应该有清单，并强迫每个人使用它们。这就像一个非常简单的点，我的意思是，你知道，它绝对不需要整本书，这本书没有，你知道，它有点通过例子来激励，这有点奇怪，因为它有点，嗯，你知道，如果你给出一个例子，别人真的不能争辩说，就像如果你说，好吧，我添加了一个清单，然后我们挽救了这个人的生命。反对这一点的论点是什么？
Like maybe you would have had some extra time on your hands. You could have eaten an extra meal or something. It's like almost indefensible or unassailable. So, you know, I wouldn't look at it as a particularly powerful self-help book or anything like that um but these stories i think were captivating um i got this one off the uh from the public library um using the libby app which is i don't know if it's only an american thing but um uh depending on where you live you might have an an app that connects to your local public library and lets you it's effectively like a kindle um uh a kindle or an audible app that's
就像也许你手头会有一些额外的时间。你可以多吃一顿饭或什么的。这几乎是不可辩驳或不可攻击的。所以，你知道，我不会把它看作是一本特别强大的自助书或类似的东西，嗯，但我认为这些故事很迷人，我从公共图书馆得到了这一本，使用Libby应用程序，我不知道它是否只是美国的东西，但，嗯，取决于你住在哪里，你可能有一个连接到你当地公共图书馆的应用程序，让你，它实际上就像一个Kindle，嗯，一个Kindle或Audible应用程序，它是
connected through the library and all the books are you borrow them um and so i i found this one on there i thought it would be pretty interesting gave it a read uh overall kind of lukewarm some some good stories but i wouldn't recommend it all right tool of the show well to say something i actually did enjoy i just finished playing not to 100 but uh i finished the main story for super mario brothers wonder um i don't know that i've talked too much about nintendo switch games um so this is a little bit off topic definitely not a tool but i really enjoyed this game to me it was just like for where i am in life it's the right complexity it was fun and challenging i didn't just you know rip right through beat every level some levels were a bit of a challenge but nothing was too
通过图书馆连接，所有的书都是你借的，所以我在这上面找到了这一本，我认为它会非常有趣，读了一下，总的来说有点不温不火，有一些好故事，但我不会推荐它，好吧，节目工具，好吧，说一些我确实喜欢的东西，我刚刚玩完，不是100%，但我完成了《超级马里奥兄弟：惊奇》的主线故事，我不知道我是否谈论太多关于任天堂Switch游戏，所以这有点离题，绝对不是工具，但我真的很喜欢这个游戏，对我来说，就像我生活中的位置一样，它是正确的复杂性，它很有趣且具有挑战性，我没有只是，你知道，直接通关，打败每一关，有些关卡有点挑战，但没有什么太
challenging so you know anytime i did sort of a session where i sat down and played the game i was able to make good progress um and it is not super super long so i was able to to feel the accomplishment of beating it and the sort of style and approach and whimsy of uh those the sort of 2d platformer but rendered in a 3d view and the kind of goofiness it doesn't take itself too seriously it's not dark it's just sort of 2D platformer, but rendered in a 3D view. And the kind of goofiness, it doesn't take itself too seriously. It's not dark. It's just sort of very lighthearted. It was a very enjoyable game to play.
具有挑战性，所以你知道，任何时候我做某种我坐下来玩游戏的环节，我都能够取得很好的进展，而且它不是超级超级长，所以我能够感受到打败它的成就感，以及那种风格和方法和异想天开，嗯，那些某种2D平台游戏，但在3D视图中渲染，以及那种愚蠢，它不把自己看得太严肃，它不黑暗，它只是某种2D平台游戏，但在3D视图中渲染。那种愚蠢，它不把自己看得太严肃。它不黑暗。它只是某种非常轻松。这是一个非常有趣的游戏。
And so if you've not checked it out and you have a Nintendo Switch, I'm sure you've heard about it. But I definitely give this one a thumbs up. I really enjoyed playing it. Cool. How does it compare to... There's a Super Mario... I think it's called Super mario wii 3d
所以如果你还没有看过它，并且你有任天堂Switch，我相信你听说过它。但我绝对给这个点赞。我真的很喜欢玩它。酷。它怎么比较……有一个超级马里奥……我想它叫超级马里奥Wii 3D
or something but it's on the switch have you played mario 3d world or oh yeah something like that so that one is 3d i think if it's the one i think about i think there's another super mario brothers new super mario brothers game as well or something um which i didn't get into the 3d world i really liked um but it's in 3d so there's a bit of a i don't know there's a a different thing to playing 2d it sort of allows them to be more creative uh in the limitation and so i kind of maybe i just old school i kind of prefer the the 2d over 3d and i don't like when the games get like super hard there are certain mario games i think get very punishing in their complexity yeah the one i was thinking i was actually called super
或者类似的东西，但它在Switch上，你玩过《马里奥3D世界》或者，哦，是的，类似的东西，所以那个是3D的，我想如果是我认为的那个，我想还有另一个《超级马里奥兄弟：新超级马里奥兄弟》游戏，或者类似的东西，嗯，我没有进入3D世界，我真的很喜欢，但它是3D的，所以有一点，我不知道，玩2D有一件不同的事情，它某种程度上允许他们更有创造力，在限制中，所以我有点，也许我只是老派，我有点更喜欢2D而不是3D，我不喜欢游戏变得超级难，我认为某些马里奥游戏在它们的复杂性上变得非常惩罚，是的，我正在想的那个实际上叫超级
mario u deluxe okay that's what was like mario and luigi yeah yeah that's the one i have now it's it's okay um i think it is pretty difficult i mean i was able to get through it but but my kids are get pretty frustrated with it um i wonder if super mario wonder is a little easier i yeah i tried that one i didn't get into it nearly the same for whatever reason the clicking there's probably different development teams i know i'm not into it enough to to sort of look but this one was definitely very well done oh cool maybe i'll check it out um all right my tool of the show is amazon q i feel like maybe i think we had it as a news uh last time that's right we had a news and i've been but yeah this uh this uh it needs like it just ate a mushroom
《马里奥U豪华版》，好吧，那就是像马里奥和路易吉，是的，是的，那是我现在有的那个，它还可以，嗯，我认为它相当困难，我的意思是，我能够通过它，但我的孩子们对它感到非常沮丧，我想知道《超级马里奥：惊奇》是否更容易一点，我，是的，我试过那个，我没有进入它，几乎同样的原因，点击，可能有不同的开发团队，我知道我没有进入它足够去，你知道，看，但这个绝对做得很好，哦酷，也许我会去看看，嗯，好吧，我的节目工具是Amazon Q，我觉得也许，我想我们上次把它作为新闻，没错，我们有一个新闻，我一直在，但是的，这个，嗯，这个，它需要，就像它刚刚吃了一个蘑菇
and now it's it's super super uh news um i'm recently building some stuff i i'm not uh ready to release it yet um but i'm getting there uh so i have to keep it all under wraps for now but um um but maybe another thing i i used amazon q4 was the linkedin bot um i don't know if we talked about the linkedin bot yes we did okay so i use it for linkedin bot i'm using it now on this new thing i'm building and um it's amazing like uh you know some things it does really well are um if i'm refactoring something so if i'm taking some code out of a function uh yeah taking some code out and making it its own function then i'll copy cut that code you know create a function paste it there and then i'll go back to the place where uh i cut the code out and amazon queues knows like call the function so it's like it's
现在它是超级超级，嗯，新闻，我最近在构建一些东西，我，我还没有准备好发布它，但我快到了，所以我现在必须把一切都保密，但，嗯，嗯，但也许另一件事，我使用Amazon Q4是LinkedIn机器人，我不知道我们是否谈论过LinkedIn机器人，是的，我们谈论过，好吧，所以我用它做LinkedIn机器人，我现在正在我正在构建的这个新东西上使用它，而且，它很神奇，就像，你知道，它做得很好的一些事情是，嗯，如果我正在重构一些东西，所以如果我正在从一个函数中取出一些代码，嗯，是的，取出一些代码并使它成为它自己的函数，然后我会复制剪切那段代码，你知道，创建一个函数，粘贴在那里，然后我会回到我剪切代码的地方，嗯，Amazon Q知道，调用该函数，所以它就像，它就像
like uh it it just like auto completed that for me um and so there's there's just like yeah there's so many things where um and when it hallucinates you know the way it works is it's just like autocomplete where you get this shadow of what it wants to write and if you press tab you know that shadow becomes a reality and if you do anything else it just it just disappears so you kind of get used to this like phantom code in front of your cursor um and over time you get used to sort of being blind to it when it's doing something that you don't really expect but then you get this like wonderful surprise when it actually does auto generate exactly what you wanted and it'll even you know sometimes they'll all generate whole
它就像，它只是像自动为我完成了它，所以有，有，只是，是的，有很多事情，嗯，当它产生幻觉时，你知道它的工作方式，它就像自动完成，你得到这个它想要写的阴影，如果你按Tab键，你知道那个阴影变成了现实，如果你做任何其他事情，它只是，它只是消失了，所以你有点习惯了光标前面的这种幻影代码，随着时间的推移，你习惯了当它做一些你并不真正期望的事情时，对它视而不见，但然后你得到这种，就像美妙的惊喜，当它实际上自动生成了你想要的东西时，它甚至会，你知道，有时它们会全部生成整个
paragraphs of of you know like maybe five six lines of code. So yeah, I think it's amazing. Folks should check it out. Obviously, as we talked about in the past, you know, don't do this for work. If you're doing this on a work computer, you should instead go to your boss and ask him to get some kind of license or figure something else out. I'm sure there's companies that have enterprise solutions there. But if you're in college, high school, building something on your own, it definitely behooves you to get an AWS Builder account and get Amazon Q. The reason I ended up on Amazon Q and not GitHub Copilot or one of these other ones is frankly just better marketing.
段落，你知道，就像也许五六行代码。所以是的，我认为它很神奇。人们应该去看看。显然，正如我们过去谈到的，你知道，不要在工作中这样做。如果你在工作电脑上这样做，你应该去问你的老板，让他获得某种许可证或想出其他办法。我相信有公司有企业解决方案。但如果你在大学，高中，自己构建一些东西，获得AWS Builder账户并获得Amazon Q绝对对你有好处。我最终使用Amazon Q而不是GitHub Copilot或其他这些的原因，坦率地说只是更好的营销。
I have the AWS extension. A lot of people have that in their VS code and they just parlayed that into a, you know, like a little notification. Like I think originally it was part of the AWS extension. So you kind of, everyone just got it for and then uh it became its own extension once they had kind of a critical mass so they did a great job marketing it i i think that all of them probably be equally good though yeah i'm excited that when these become commonplace and able to be used at work and there's like a well-established practice around them but yeah for now i've i've not delved into these but i definitely
我有AWS扩展。很多人在他们的VS代码中有那个，他们只是把它变成了一个，你知道，像一个小通知。就像我认为最初它是AWS扩展的一部分。所以你有点，每个人都得到了它，然后，嗯，一旦他们有了一定的临界质量，它就成了它自己的扩展，所以他们在营销它方面做得很好，我认为它们可能都同样好，是的，我很兴奋，当这些变得普遍并能够在工作中使用，并且围绕它们有完善的实践时，但是的，目前，我还没有深入研究这些，但我绝对
kind of want to yeah i mean i'd be curious for you know your coding for you know c++ and these things if if it would be as useful my guess is it'd probably struggle oh no no don't tell me that i want to envision it being panacea uh yeah i mean well okay so a couple of things that are just first principles right like it's not going to know like oh this memory address is actually like a fifo in hardware or something right so oh okay well yeah fair enough but oh i mean that would be the day when you can feed a i don't have to do that quite as much anymore thankfully but if you feed it a data sheet and it would build out for you uh communications protocol like that would be amazing oh man that'd be awesome that'd be cool
有点想，是的，我的意思是，我会很好奇，你知道，你的编码，你知道，C++和这些东西，如果它会同样有用，我的猜测是它可能会挣扎，哦不，不，别告诉我，我想把它设想为万灵药，是的，我的意思是，好吧，所以有几件事只是第一原则，对吧，它不会知道，哦，这个内存地址实际上是硬件中的FIFO或类似的东西，所以，哦，好吧，嗯，是的，有道理，但是，哦，我的意思是，那将是你可以喂给人工智能的那一天，我不必再那样做了，谢天谢地，但如果你喂给它一个数据表，它会为你构建通信协议，那将是惊人的，哦天哪，那太棒了，那太酷了
all right now i'm just fantasizing all right somebody out the topic of resume writing this came from a gentleman i never give last names because i don't know who uh wants that or not but matthew c um we had a discussion um on linkedin uh it actually matthew sent me a linkedin message. He said that you really enjoyed the show. He's wondering if I could take a look at his resume. Fortunately, my LinkedIn AI didn't flag it as spam, which it has flagged actually, it has a couple of false positives. So if you're listening, I do apologize for that. But this one, you know, let through. And um um and so yeah i talked i talked to matthew gave him some tips on his resume and i said hey what if uh we did a show on this and and gave you credit and he was um thankfully uh you know really supportive of us doing that um so thank you matthew to you for inspiring the show to start at the maybe obvious why even uh have a resume i mean in them in uh back in the good old days no they were that good uh it is actually a little you'd show up and uh you know you may have gotten a job interview in some various ways. And then they would ask you for a printed out and you would have like a little leather,
好吧，现在我只是在幻想，好吧，有人关于简历写作的话题，这来自一位先生，我从不给姓氏，因为我不知道谁想要那个，或者不想要，但马修·C，我们进行了一次讨论，嗯，在LinkedIn上，实际上马修给我发了一条LinkedIn消息。他说他真的很喜欢这个节目。他想知道我是否可以看看他的简历。幸运的是，我的LinkedIn人工智能没有把它标记为垃圾邮件，它实际上已经标记了，它有几个误报。所以如果你在听，我为此道歉。但这个，你知道，放过了。而且，嗯，嗯，所以是的，我和马修谈过，给了他一些关于他简历的建议，我说，嘿，如果我们做一个关于这个的节目，并给你功劳，他，嗯，谢天谢地，嗯，真的支持我们这样做，所以谢谢你，马修，激励了这个节目开始，在也许显而易见的地方，为什么还要有简历，我的意思是，在，嗯，回到美好的旧时光，不，它们那么好，它实际上有点，你会出现，嗯，你知道，你可能以某种方式获得了工作面试。然后他们会要求你打印出来，你会有像一个小皮革，
or at least we, that's what we always have, like these little leather binders. And you would unzip them and pull out, you know, on a printed, very nice paper that you would buy specifically for printing resumes. And you would, you know, hand them over. I haven't done that in a very, very, very, very long time now. Most of the time, everybody gets copies electronically, because in order to apply for a job, you have to go to some portal on some website. And the almost very first thing you need to do is upload your resume, and then proceed to type in most of the information from your resume
或者至少我们，这就是我们总是有的，像这些小皮革活页夹。你会拉开拉链，拿出，你知道，在打印的，非常好的纸上，你会专门为打印简历而买。然后你会，你知道，把它们交给他们。我现在已经很久很久很久很久没有那样做了。大多数时候，每个人都以电子方式获得副本，因为为了申请工作，你必须去某个网站上的某个门户网站。你几乎需要做的第一件事就是上传你的简历，然后继续输入你简历中的大部分信息
into various forms. But you know, it's an expectation that you have a resume when you apply for jobs today. And the reason they have you upload it is to share it with everyone, to have it recorded for other potential openings. It is a thing. But it's also because they do run keyword detection. They try to categorize it. And when you kind of read on the internet, you see people bemoaning this. And I do agree it's kind of problematic. But it's also very difficult, especially if you work at a large company and get many thousands of resumes, trying to categorize so that the right people look at the right resumes.
进入各种表格。但你知道，当你今天申请工作时，期望你有一份简历。他们让你上传它的原因是与每个人分享，为其他潜在的空缺记录它。它是一件事。但这也是因为他们确实运行关键字检测。他们试图对其进行分类。当你有点在互联网上阅读时，你会看到人们为此哀叹。我确实同意这有点问题。但这也非常困难，特别是如果你在一家大公司工作并收到成千上万份简历，试图分类以便合适的人看合适的简历。
Because as a person who does hire sometimes you'll get a dump of resumes and if they're if they're mismatched it becomes very difficult to trudge through them and say like hey these are totally the wrong kinds of people like it's not that they're good or bad it's just they're not this is not a match for the kind of role that i'm looking for and so i need to find a way to get access to the ones that I need. And so I think having a resume, probably pretty obvious, but I'll give one non-obvious thing, which is as you, and maybe you're already there. I don't want to make an assumption.
因为作为一个有时确实雇佣的人，你会得到一堆简历，如果它们不匹配，就很难费力地浏览它们并说，嘿，这些完全是错误类型的人，这不是说他们好或坏，只是他们不匹配，这不是我正在寻找的角色类型，所以我需要找到一种方法来获得我需要的那些。所以我认为有一份简历，可能很明显，但我会给出一件不明显的事情，那就是当你，也许你已经到了那里。我不想做假设。
But one of the things is as you move through your career, it becomes a little harder to remember some of the exact details that you want to provide for previous positions and roles. And so it's really a log, you may trim stuff off as they become older and older. But having those things written down so that next time you go to apply for a job, you're sort of appending and then trimming down is actually really, really useful to have that sort of log that you can go through and be able to curate for future applications yep yep yeah totally um so what is a resume um there's actually not that much variance uh most people follow you know pretty standard formats um sometimes i've interviewed uh designers and and more creative folks who who have also you know done interesting things to their resume but but in a lot of those cases
但其中一件事是，当你职业生涯中前进时，记住你想要为以前的职位和角色提供的一些确切细节变得有点困难。所以它确实是一个日志，你可能会在它们变得越来越老时修剪掉东西。但把这些东西写下来，以便下次你去申请工作时，你有点在追加，然后修剪掉，实际上是非常非常有用的，拥有那种你可以浏览并能够为未来申请策划的日志，是的，是的，是的，完全正确，嗯，所以什么是简历，实际上没有那么大的差异，大多数人遵循，你知道，相当标准的格式，有时我采访过设计师和更具创造力的人，他们也，你知道，对他们的简历做了有趣的事情，但在很多情况下
those folks also have a portfolio so you really can't go wrong on your resume but but uh for them but for you know for professionals i think you, try to keep it to one page. I think that's important. I think, you know, that way everything is just, you know, fitting on one screen. And it usually starts out with your name and some generic information. Some people have put, you know, whether they need a visa or not, you know, that can be a important point that sometimes I've seen in the very top line of the resume, usually just some basic information, where does this person live, you know, their name, etc, phone number, potentially. And then he goes, it goes straight into, you know, various education and work experiences um and accomplishments there
那些人也有作品集，所以你的简历绝对不会出错，但对于专业人士来说，我认为尽量控制在一页纸以内。我认为这很重要。这样一来，所有内容都能刚好显示在一个屏幕上。简历通常以你的姓名和一些基本信息开头。有些人会写明是否需要签证，这有时是一个重要的点，我有时会在简历的最顶端看到，通常只是一些基本信息，比如这个人住在哪里、姓名、电话号码等。然后直接进入各种教育和工作经历，以及在这些经历中取得的成就。
and then usually at the end it will end with um uh you know a list of of let's say skills or trades that this person has so this person might be an expert on compiler optimization and so they'll put compiler optimization um you know they'll put compiler optimization. And sometimes people will put more soft skills and things like led their volleyball team in college or something like that. This is a little different than a CV. So a CV, which I think is Latin, right? Curriculum vitae or something like that.
通常在最后会列出一份技能或专长清单，比如这个人可能是编译器优化方面的专家，他们就会写上编译器优化。有时人们会写一些软技能，比如在大学里担任排球队队长之类的。这与简历（CV）略有不同。CV 这个词应该是拉丁语，对吧？Curriculum vitae 之类的。
I think that's right. So a CV will list out, typically list out all of your research papers, uh, um, or depending on how many you have, it might be a subset of them. Um, and so that's where it can take several pages to list out. But, but, you know, even if you're writing a CV, I would, um would um you know effectively have effectively a resume on the first page and then have a section of you know notable papers and awards and then you can have a list and that that list might be four or five six pages but it's it's basically a glossary of your uh you know favorite research journal papers and awards um so you're still basically writing a resume and adding some content to it
我想是这样。所以 CV 通常会列出你所有的研究论文，或者根据你的论文数量，列出其中的一部分。这可能需要好几页纸才能列完。但是，即使你在写 CV，我也建议你在第一页放一份有效的简历，然后加上一个重要论文和奖项的部分，后面可以附上一份清单，那份清单可能有四五六页长，但它基本上是你最喜欢的期刊论文和奖项的词汇表，所以你本质上还是在写一份简历，并在此基础上增加了一些内容。
yeah i would agree if for some reason you need to go past one page and some people say it's okay to be on two sometimes people have a very strong preference for one. And if you're going to two, unless there's a really, really good reason, it tends to just draw on too long. So if you have stuff that requires more, I would say prepare two different. I think that's what Jason's alluding to as well as like, have two different documents. One is your resume, concise one page. And then you can even say on there, you know, more details or CV available if needed, or just, you know, something and then have another document, which is longer and goes into more details if there's really things that you need to list out. So here's another one though, Jason, I don't know how you feel about it.
是的，我同意。如果因为某种原因你需要超过一页，有些人说两页也可以，但有时人们对一页纸有非常强烈的偏好。如果你要写到两页，除非有非常非常充分的理由，否则往往会显得太冗长。所以如果你有需要更多篇幅的内容，我会建议准备两份不同的文档。我想这也是 Jason 所暗示的，即准备两份不同的文档。一份是你的简历，简洁的一页纸。你甚至可以在上面写上“如有需要可提供更多详细信息或 CV”，或者类似的话，然后准备另一份更长、更详细的文档，以备确实需要列出更多内容时使用。不过这里还有一点，Jason，我不知道你怎么看。
Some people say having a GitHub on the resume, a GitHub link is a requirement. Oh, that's a good question. I think, okay, i think you should only put things on your resume if they're good um this you know it's a great answer okay yeah i mean i think this is um your resume is not uh your your autobiography right you're you're you're uh maybe your autobiography is also rose-tinted but if i was to write an autobiography i would definitely call out all the extremely dumb things I've done in my life, along with all the things I'm proud of. So this is not that.
有些人说在简历上放 GitHub 链接是必须的。哦，这是个好问题。我觉得，好吧，我认为只有当你的 GitHub 内容很棒时才应该放上去。这是一个很好的回答。我的意思是，你的简历不是你的自传，对吧？也许你的自传也是经过美化的，但如果我要写自传，我肯定会写出我一生中做过的所有极其愚蠢的事情，以及我引以为豪的事情。所以简历不是那样的。
This is supposed to be the absolute best side of you. No flaws, nothing. And so your GitHub could be the best part of your resume. And I think if it is, you could have an entire section dedicated to that i've seen that um work to really good effect where they'll say here's a personal projects section and the header will have their github and then they'll have a bunch of projects um and if if they're popular they'll have stars um if they're not popular a good thing to do is to say kind of what technical uh problem this solves and um you know maybe what projects it's similar to so if you built for example an automatic differentiation
这应该是你最完美的一面。没有瑕疵，什么都没有。所以你的 GitHub 可能是你简历中最精彩的部分。如果确实如此，你可以专门开辟一个部分来展示它。我见过这种做法效果非常好，他们会写一个“个人项目”部分，标题下放上 GitHub 链接，然后列出一堆项目。如果项目很受欢迎，会有星标；如果不太受欢迎，一个好的做法是说明它解决了什么技术问题，以及它类似于什么项目。比如，如果你构建了一个自动微分引擎。
engine uh and a dsl language that, then you could say, you know, similar to PyTorch. Uh, and so, you know, you built your own, obviously it's hard to eat into the market share of PyTorch or TensorFlow, but, but you built something on that, uh, you know, in that milieu. Um, so yeah, I think generally it's really, really important to have, to have that kind of portfolio, just like any artist or creative person would. But don't just put your GitHub and you have like zero repositories or something.
和一个 DSL 语言，那么你可以说，类似于 PyTorch。虽然你构建了自己的东西，显然很难撼动 PyTorch 或 TensorFlow 的市场份额，但你确实在那个领域构建了一些东西。所以，是的，我认为拥有那种作品集非常非常重要，就像任何艺术家或创意人士一样。但不要只放一个 GitHub 链接，里面却一个仓库都没有。
That's not helpful. Yeah, I agree. I've seen, and I know people who say you have to have your GitHub, but there's a lot of personal preference here. But if I if you put your GitHub, I think it's you're saying there's important to have spent space on your resume to put it. So I'll go visit it. And if I go visit it, and it's like, oh, you just have various forks of projects that,
那没什么帮助。是的，我同意。我见过，也认识一些人说必须放 GitHub，但这很大程度上取决于个人偏好。但如果你放了 GitHub，我认为你是在暗示简历上占据的空间是有价值的。所以我回去看。如果我点进去，发现里面只是各种项目的 fork，
you know, require you to fork it for some reason, or like configuration files, or just things that are obviously, you know, class projects where you started with the template. Yeah, it just doesn't feel like, you know, what, what this isn't helping me, it's not really hurting me. But like, I would just leave it off and save save the person the time if there's not something there that you're really trying to show off. But I think it can depend um i think some people don't don't hesitate if you have stuff even if it's not having a lot of stars or isn't really popular if it's code that you wrote that you know you worked on you should be proud of it and you should put it um but if it's code that you just copied or forked or is a you know was a group project. I don't know.
或者是因为某种原因需要 fork 的东西，或者是配置文件，或者是显而易见的课堂作业，你只是从模板开始做的。这感觉没什么帮助，虽然也没什么坏处。但我会选择不放，如果里面没有你真正想展示的东西，就别浪费别人的时间了。但我认为这取决于具体情况，如果你有自己写的代码，即使没有很多星标或不是很受欢迎，只要是你参与过的，你应该为此感到自豪，就应该放上去。但如果是你只是复制、fork 的代码，或者是小组项目，我就不知道了。
Yep. Yeah, I totally agree. I mean, the thing too is if you don't put it, then people won't think about it. It's a Streisand effect, right? If you put the GitHub repo and yeah, as you said, it's all like University of Chicago, course 12, you know, zero stars and
是的，我完全同意。我的意思是，如果你不放，人们就不会去想它。这就是“史翠珊效应”，对吧？如果你放了 GitHub 仓库，正如你所说，里面全是芝加哥大学某某课程的作业，零星标，而且
there's no tests or anything. Then now people like, you know, it's and there's no tests or anything, then now people like, you know, it's actually kind of worse than just not putting anything. All right. Well, I think maybe we'll go through some do's and don'ts. And so I'll start off with a couple of do's. Definitely be specific. So when you're writing that, Hey, I was at this company. I mean, that's, you know, very specific, but the dates that you were there, the location, those things are good. Um, you can put the skills used. I think that's, that's important too. But also like when you write projects, you know, say specifically things that will make sense to
没有测试之类的。那么现在人们会觉得，这实际上比什么都不放还要糟糕。好吧，我想我们来过一遍一些“该做”和“不该做”的事项。我先从几个“该做”的开始。一定要具体。所以当你写“我在某某公司工作”时，这很具体，但你在那里的日期、地点，这些都是好的。你可以写上所使用的技能。我认为这也很重要。但当你写项目时，要具体说明那些对
people who may not be super familiar with the jargon of what you were doing so if you were you know doing something in a database but your database had a particular internal name probably not super useful if you're applying externally to put the internal names of those databases so put down you know database you know schema design right um but definitely be specific about not the work that was being done on the project but the work that you were doing on the project right and so we see i see a lot of people that you spend time asking because they're pretty junior and they put a pretty high level project and it's what did you do what were you responsible for um and i think and it's not again you don't have to be nervous or ashamed or bashful about it.
可能不太熟悉你所做工作的术语的人来说有意义的事情。所以如果你是在数据库方面做了一些事情，但你的数据库有一个特定的内部名称，如果你申请外部职位，写上这些内部名称可能没什么用。所以写上“数据库模式设计”之类的。但一定要具体说明，不是项目本身做了什么，而是你在项目中做了什么。我看到很多人因为资历尚浅，写了一个很高大上的项目，我会问你具体做了什么，你负责什么。而且，再次强调，你不必为此感到紧张、羞愧或难为情。
But just put down the specific thing that you were doing. I was writing unit tests, I was doing integration, whatever it is, that's fine. Put that there. Don't put you know, I was responsible for a project that, you know, did $100 million. And, you know, was 10 000 lines of code that you know had a sla of you know 99.999 uptime it's like okay this sounds like a group of people were doing this what were you doing yeah it's a good call out too because it'll give you it'll give the the person looking at the resume some some idea of your kind of compass right so for example if someone says you know i um you know implemented the python standards committee at my company and i made like 20 or 30 decisions around like different syntax and all these things then it's excuse me, it's going to paint a picture to, uh, interviewers that you're somebody who, who is, you know, really cares about
只要写下你具体做的事情就行。我写了单元测试，我做了集成，无论是什么，都没问题，写上去。不要写“我负责了一个价值一亿美元的项目，有 1 万行代码，SLA 达到 99.999% 的正常运行时间”。这听起来像是一群人在做这件事，你到底做了什么？是的，这提醒得很好，因为它会让看简历的人对你的能力范围有个概念。例如，如果有人说“我在公司实施了 Python 标准委员会，我就不同的语法和所有这些事情做出了 20 或 30 个决定”，那么这会给面试官留下一个印象，即你是一个真正关心
dev infra and the developer ecosystem and all of that. Um, you know, conversely, if you say, Hey, you know, I wrote this code that added this much incremental revenue, uh, to the revenue to the bottom line of the company, and I worked on these features that caused this many more customers to come in the door. Then people know, okay, this is somebody who's very product-focused, and they're going to be a good person to be in between the business and the engineering.
开发基础设施和开发者生态系统的人。相反，如果你说“我编写的代码为公司带来了这么多增量收入，我参与的这些功能吸引了这么多客户”，那么人们就会知道，这是一个以产品为导向的人，他们将成为连接业务和工程的桥梁。
So isolating your specific contributions helps the interviewer know like what where your what your strength is yeah i mean i think the i guess i know kind of corollary the the the sort of thought there if you i mean i'll be a little harsh if you try to scam your way into getting the interview people are going to figure it out especially in the kinds of jobs right that we're talking about here almost always there's going to be a technical portion of the interview and it's going to become obvious so even if you happen to put something down to score an interview either when they go to check your references or they're talking to you or it'll come out and so you'll just have wasted time and then people are going to be irritated and upset or you're interviewing for a role that's a higher level than you'll be
所以明确你的具体贡献有助于面试官了解你的优势所在。是的，我的意思是，如果我稍微严厉一点，如果你试图通过欺骗手段获得面试机会，人们最终会发现的。特别是在我们讨论的这类工作中，几乎总会有技术面试环节，真相会大白。所以即使你碰巧写了些东西来获得面试机会，当他们去核实你的推荐人，或者与你交谈时，事情总会暴露出来。你只是浪费了时间，人们会感到恼火和沮丧，或者你面试的职位级别高于你
able to successfully interview for and sure you may tell yourself well there's like a very outside chance that like i'll score it i i don't know the opposite is is worse right like the opposite that you get sort of kicked out of the queue because people are like no this person is just like there's just no good rather than oh they were miscategorized right right and even like at a more granular level you might just not get the right job for you like maybe you really should be spending half your time with these python committees you know setting the course of the company like and the language specs and all that um but you know you like really tried to fluff up like your like impact numbers and because of that now you're on some product team
能够胜任的水平。当然，你可能会告诉自己，也许我有一线希望通过面试。但我不知道，反过来情况更糟，即你因为人们觉得“不，这个人根本不行”而被踢出候选名单，而不是“哦，他们被错误分类了”。即使在更细致的层面上，你可能只是没有得到最适合你的工作。也许你真的应该花一半时间在那些 Python 委员会上，决定公司的方向和语言规范，但你却试图夸大你的影响力数字，结果现在你在某个产品团队里，
you could have been on some other team it was a better fit etc so so it's like you know represent yourself i guess it's i want to make sure that we're not creating contradiction here like obviously you know the time you accidentally deleted the production database you know don't put that on your resume uh but you know of all the good aspects of you, you know, be faithful to that sort of distribution of talent and represent that as faithfully as possible on the resume. Another thing is any item that you put on your resume, be ready to talk about. And so if you put down, hey, you know, I've seen, I'll give a goofy one first. Someone put down, oh oh i can solve a rubik's cube in under a minute and then so the interviewer thought it'd be funny they brought a rubik's cube
而你本可以去另一个更适合你的团队。所以，要真实地展示自己。我想确保我们没有自相矛盾，显然，你意外删除生产数据库的那次经历，不要写在简历上。但对于你所有的优点，要忠实于你的才能分布，并尽可能真实地在简历上呈现出来。另一件事是，简历上的任何项目，都要准备好谈论它。如果有人写下，我先举个滑稽的例子，有人写“我可以在一分钟内解开魔方”，面试官觉得很有趣，就带了一个魔方，
and asked the person to solve it um and so i mean that's a bit of a goofy goofy example um and they just put it in there be funny but they got called out on it but i've seen people put down you know i i'm an you know i'm an expert or you know i, and then they put down six programming languages. And then someone starts talking to them about one of them, like, well, I used it for a tiny project one time once. And it's like, well, maybe you needed some way to qualify that or call it out. But similarly, it's very frustrating
要求那个人解开它。这是一个有点滑稽的例子，他们只是为了好玩写上去的，结果被当场拆穿了。但我见过有人写“我是专家”，然后列出了六种编程语言。当有人开始和他们谈论其中一种时，他们说“哦，我曾经在一个小项目里用过一次”。那么，也许你需要某种方式来限定或说明它。同样，这非常令人沮丧，
when someone puts down that they worked on a project that's relevant to the role that they're interviewing for at a company and you ask them to talk about that project. And I've had people just tell me, I don't remember or I don't know. And it's like, why did you put it on your resume? Like you have other stuff here.
当有人写他们参与了一个与所申请职位相关的项目，而你让他们谈谈那个项目时，他们却告诉我“我不记得了”或者“我不知道”。这就像，你为什么要把它写在简历上？你简历上还有其他东西啊。
Like what is it that you do remember, right? Like be ready. If you put it on there, people are gonna ask you about it. Yeah, that's a really, really, really good point. Yeah. Don't put that, you know, 20 languages unless you've been listening to the show for at least a few months.
你到底记得什么？所以要做好准备。如果你写上去了，人们就会问你。是的，这真的是一个非常非常好的观点。不要写那 20 种语言，除非你已经听这个节目至少几个月了。
There we go. How many languages do you put down? If you were going to put them down, Jason, I'm curious, like what threshold would you have to cross? Like how many do you think you'd put? You know, that's a great question so okay i have maybe a slightly different view than patrick although it's very similar so i think that you can put down any language as long as you're prepared to like really understand it between now
就是这样。你会写多少种语言？如果你要写的话，Jason，我很好奇，你会设定什么门槛？你觉得你会写多少种？这是一个很好的问题。好吧，我的看法可能和 Patrick 略有不同，尽管非常相似。我认为你可以写下任何语言，只要你准备好在现在到
and when you're interviewed so for example let's say you're interviewing for a game development job right so and let's say you have like a you've done a few small projects in c-sharp right so you can put c-sharp but if your resume gets through the screener and you land the interview, you're going to need to take a week off whatever you're doing and cram C sharp really, really hard because you don't want to show up. I think it's OK to flex a little bit on the interview as long as you're prepared to back it up by either knowing that language really well or getting like really up to speed with it very quickly okay so i will accept this that you say that if you're willing to at least do one of the technical interview programming problems in any language you put down right yeah we're on the same for the interview okay i i will buy this premise all right so how many how many for me personally yeah what would you how many would you put again not saying like you like you might be plus one because you are trying to target
面试之间的时间里真正掌握它。例如，假设你正在面试一份游戏开发工作，你做过几个 C# 的小项目，那么你可以写 C#。但如果你的简历通过了筛选并获得了面试机会，你需要请一周假，拼命突击 C#，因为你不想在面试中露怯。我认为在面试中稍微灵活一点是可以的，只要你准备好通过非常精通该语言，或者非常快速地掌握它来支撑你的简历。好吧，我接受这一点，你说如果你愿意在面试中用你写下的任何语言完成一道技术编程题。是的，我们对面试的看法一致。好吧，我接受这个前提。那么，对我个人而言，你会写多少种？
a specific job and it's close enough to something you've done i'll buy that but like how many would you feel comfortable yeah so here's here's what i think for me personally obviously different for different people but um i think that if i cover like the three or four most popular ones for my profession. So my case, that would be Python, C++, JavaScript slash TypeScript. And what would the fourth one be for AI? I would actually, you know, I would probably put something to the effect of like bash Unix kind of scripting. I mean, I haven't thought about this in a while, but something like that. Right.
再次强调，不是说你可能会多写一种，因为你是在针对特定职位，而且它和你做过的事情很接近，我接受这一点。但你觉得写多少种比较舒服？对我个人来说，显然每个人情况不同，但我认为如果我涵盖了我的专业领域中最流行的三四种语言。对我来说，那就是 Python、C++、JavaScript/TypeScript。AI 的第四种语言会是什么？我可能会写上类似 Bash Unix 脚本之类的东西。我的意思是，我有一段时间没想过这个问题了，但类似的东西。
And so I would put those and then I would just assume that companies know like, OK, all of our AI is in Swift. But we know that like, yes, there's a lot of people who are really smart who don't haven't used Swift yet. And so they're going to have to interview Python people. That's, that's the way I would approach it. Yep. If they wanted it for AI, they would, they would just let you learn Swift on the job. Yeah, exactly. Um, now if you're, yeah, go ahead. I was going to say, now if I'm like, let's say I'm junior engineer, you know, straight out of college, I would probably try to figure out
我会写上这些，然后我会假设公司知道，好吧，我们所有的 AI 都是用 Swift 写的。但我们知道，有很多非常聪明的人还没用过 Swift。所以他们将不得不面试 Python 背景的人。这就是我的处理方式。是的，如果他们想要 AI 方面的人才，他们会让你在工作中学习 Swift。是的，完全正确。现在，如果你是，请继续。我本来想说，如果我是初级工程师，刚从大学毕业，我可能会试着弄清楚
what language the company is that I'm applying to, like what language they need. And I would put that language and I would study it hard if I got the interview. That's what I would, that's what 19 year old, 22 year old, whatever Jason would do. All right, fair enough. So I would put two.
我申请的公司用什么语言，他们需要什么语言。我会写上那种语言，如果我获得了面试机会，我会努力学习它。这就是 19 岁、22 岁的 Jason 会做的事情。好吧，有道理。所以我会写两种。
And I hear your points. I'm, I'm not, I'm not saying no on them, but my, my reason for bringing this up. So, so you said three, four, okay. I give it the bash thing. Okay. Maybe everyone could add that. I don't know. I don't actually consider my bash scripting to be that great. So maybe I would have two tiers and in total have maybe four maybe maybe three um but we routinely see people out of college six seven eight programming languages written down and i'm just like no there's no way it's like you know what is the bar here if i asked you even just basic questions in a random one of these what is the chance you're actually going to to you know be able to answer these yeah it's it's it's tough because uh like for example if you're applying to do um uh you know i work at a self-driving car company if you're applying to do work on the car
我听到了你的观点。我并不是说不同意，但我提出这一点的原因是，你说了三四种，好吧。我接受 Bash 那种。也许每个人都可以加上那个。我不知道。我其实并不认为我的 Bash 脚本写得有多好。所以也许我会分两个层级，总共写四种，也许三种。但我们经常看到刚毕业的学生写了六七八种编程语言，我心想，不，这不可能。这里的标准是什么？如果我问你其中任何一种语言的基本问题，你真的能回答出来的几率是多少？是的，这很难，因为例如，如果你申请在一家自动驾驶汽车公司工作，如果你申请从事汽车相关的工作，
you're gonna need to know c++ and so literally people who don't have C++ on their resume, they just, the resume just doesn't make it through. And so, and so if C++ is like, you've done a few examples, you know, you've done, I guess, I think the part where we agree is you need to be able to show up and do a 60 minute interview in every single language you put on there. Now, I think that there, it's probably not too hard to get to the point where you could do a technical interview in six languages. It doesn't mean you've
你需要懂 C++。所以那些简历上没有 C++ 的人，简历根本过不了筛选。所以，如果 C++ 对你来说只是做过几个例子，我想我们达成一致的地方是，你需要能够参加并完成任何你写在简历上的语言的 60 分钟面试。现在，我认为要达到能够用六种语言进行技术面试的程度，可能并不太难。这并不意味着你在其中任何一种语言中都有多年的经验，但，是的，这是一个有趣的话题。
had years of experience in any of them, but yeah, I, I, I guess, yeah, this is a interesting topic okay there's some variance here i if you in your example i mean i've hired people who i needed to know c++ i'm going to ask them oh okay use this hash map standard unordered map what's the default insertion policy for standard unordered map hey what is that like you know what is this thing going to look like what is if you have this kind of error that you know equates to a symptom of a stack overflow what is your suspected reason why or i'm going to write code up on the board that introduces and you know array index out of bounds and asks you hey what's going to happen here and the answer is undefined and then we should talk to what are potential things that could happen so oh see that's totally different see what i had in my simply no that's an extension that's a yeah if i needed a
这里有一些差异。在你的例子中，如果我雇佣的人需要懂 C++，我会问他们，哦，使用这个哈希映射，标准 unordered_map 的默认插入策略是什么？嘿，那是什么？如果出现这种错误，等同于栈溢出的症状，你怀疑的原因是什么？或者我会在白板上写一段代码，引入数组越界错误，问你，嘿，这里会发生什么？答案是未定义的，然后我们应该讨论可能发生的情况。哦，看，那完全不同。我所说的只是一个扩展。
specific language and i wanted to check that you you know actually know that language but yeah so this one this one's interesting okay so this one's people should be thoughtful about yeah i mean in my mind i had this mental model where like you're using one of these uh tools to interview right like like you're saying like yeah i could i could write leet code problems in one of these six languages yeah right but but you're totally right if well so that's an interesting thing right let's dive into this so if someone puts let's say python as one of their languages but they're a junior engineer you know they they graduated last year from college right or they got a bunch of coursera certificates last
如果你需要一种特定的语言，并且想检查你是否真的懂那种语言。所以这个很有趣。人们应该深思熟虑。在我的脑海里，我有一个心理模型，就像你说的，你使用这些工具中的一种来面试，比如我可以用这六种语言中的任何一种写 LeetCode 题目。但你是完全正确的，如果……这是一个有趣的事情。如果有人写了 Python 作为他们的语言之一，但他们是初级工程师，去年刚从大学毕业，或者去年拿了一堆 Coursera 证书，
year um or let's just stick with c++ they let's say they only have one language and it's c++ they'll probably still not be able to answer those questions, right? So I think it matters whether someone says they can do a link. There's basically like three levels. There's, I bet I can learn this in a week to where I could be as productive as anybody else, like any other person who is not an expert. then there's like i could fix like weird problems and then there's like i'm a guru it's kind of like there's three levels probably more than that don't put guru on any of them just as this don't ever put your guru but uh but you're right i think if if someone uh sort of transcends a number of languages right if someone
或者我们坚持用 C++，假设他们只有一种语言，就是 C++，他们可能仍然无法回答那些问题，对吧？所以我认为一个人是否说他们能做某事很重要。基本上有三个层次。第一，我敢打赌我可以在一周内学会它，达到和其他非专家一样高效的程度；第二，我可以修复奇怪的问题；第三，我是大师。大概有三个层次，可能更多。不要在任何语言后面写“大师”，千万别写。但你是对的，如果有人超越了多种语言，
just puts c++ they're really not telling you whether they can pass the kind of questions that you just asked and i wonder if there's maybe a way that in their resume they can yeah all right so i'll amend i'll amend what i'm saying based on on you did. I think when you list them out, maybe having tiers, like, you know, not as an expert, it's like proficient in, and then maybe a couple languages, you know, proficient.
如果有人只写了 C++，他们并没有告诉你他们是否能通过你刚才问的那种问题。我想知道是否有一种方法可以在简历中体现出来。好吧，我会根据你所说的修改我的观点。我认为当你列出它们时，也许可以分层，比如“非专家”，或者“精通”，然后写上几种语言。
I'm trying to think of like wordsmith it, but like proficient and like, you know, familiar with, and then maybe a few other languages. Oh, yeah, right. Something like that. But I'll amend. I think you're right.
我在想怎么措辞，比如“精通”和“熟悉”，然后也许还有其他几种语言。哦，是的，对。类似的东西。但我会修改。我认为你是对的。
I wouldn't be harsh. So I'm not going to bring someone in and ask these kinds of questions. Unless, and we didn't talk about this, when you're listing out your experiences, you should definitely write what languages each one of them was primarily in or which language or languages each of them was in.
我不会那么严厉。所以我不会把人叫来问这些问题。除非，我们之前没谈到，当你列出你的经历时，你一定要写明每一项经历主要使用的语言，或者每一项经历中涉及的一种或多种语言。
So I'm going to look, if I need someone with actual years, not out of college, but someone who says they are a C++ programmer, because I go look in their resume and it says they spent four years in this project doing C++, then I'm going to expect them to have some day to day. I mean, I was trying to give extreme examples to evoke a response, but like, I'm going to expect them to have some familiarity if they've listed that. That's that totally makes sense. I think that's actually the way to do it. Because all
所以我会看，如果我需要一个有实际工作年限的人，而不是刚毕业的学生，但有人说他们是 C++ 程序员，因为我去看他们的简历，上面写着他们在某个项目中花了四年时间使用 C++，那么我会期望他们有一些日常经验。我的意思是，我试图举极端例子来引发回应，但如果他们列出了这些，我会期望他们有一定的熟悉度。这完全说得通。我认为这确实是正确的方法。因为所有
these things like expert guru proficient, they're all very qualitative, right? But if you were to say C++ for 10 years straight, well, then, then yeah, I think it's fair to ask that person, like which of the different standard maps is better and which cases and whatever. That must have come up in the past 10 years. So yeah, I think that's a good way to go about it. We've made progress. The world is a better place.
这些词，比如专家、大师、精通，都是非常定性的，对吧？但如果你写“连续 10 年使用 C++”，那么，是的，我认为问那个人哪种标准映射在什么情况下更好是公平的。这在过去 10 年里肯定出现过。所以，是的，我认为这是一个很好的处理方式。我们取得了进展。世界变得更美好了。
That's right. So don'ts on your resume. The biggest one is don't have mistakes. I had a, not a mistake, but something that was confusing on your resume, the biggest one is don't have mistakes. I had a, not a mistake, but something that was confusing on my resume where, and I think you probably had this too, Patrick, where, you know, I was a student and I was working at the same time. Now for master's degrees is very common, but it's not very common for PhD students to also work um and so this really threw people for a loop and uh um you know and what ended up like really helping here was that i put very specific dates so originally i put you know i started my phd in in uh 2004 and i finished it in
没错。所以简历上的“不该做”。最重要的一点是不要有错误。我曾经有过，不是错误，但简历上有一些令人困惑的地方。Patrick，你可能也有过，我当时既是学生又在同时工作。现在对于硕士学位来说这很常见，但对于博士生来说，同时工作并不常见。所以这让人们感到困惑。最终真正有帮助的是，我写了非常具体的日期。最初我写的是，我 2004 年开始读博，2010 年完成，
2010 or whatever it was. But instead I put really specific like, okay, this is the day I started. This is the day I got a master's degree. This is the day that I worked. And then this is the day I finished my dissertation. And so I think just being really specific, like ambiguity is a form of a mistake when it comes to your resume. And being really specific
或者类似的时间。但我改成了非常具体的日期，比如，这是我开始的日期，这是我获得硕士学位的日期，这是我工作的日期，这是我完成论文的日期。所以我认为非常具体很重要，因为模糊不清在简历中就是一种错误。而且非常具体
helps a lot and definitely don't have mistakes if you put just from personal experience if i see someone and they like the dates don't really make sense like they kind of work two jobs at the same time and they didn't work and the dates aren't really lining up, especially if they don't match their years of experience, like 10 years of experience, but you only worked for three years, then I'll just say this isn't like, this is actually kind of a segue I'll go into briefly. Managers have to look at a ton of resumes, right? And typically we'll only need to hire one, two, maybe three people at the most at any given time. And so the goal isn't necessarily to like spend an unbelievable amount of time to get the absolute best person and squeeze out every single percent of the interview
非常有帮助。绝对不要有错误。根据个人经验，如果我看到一个人的简历，日期对不上，比如他们同时做两份工作，或者日期根本对不上，特别是如果它们与他们的工作年限不匹配，比如写着 10 年经验，但实际上只工作了 3 年，那么我会说，这其实是一个简短的过渡。经理们必须看大量的简历，对吧？通常在任何特定时间，我们最多只需要雇佣一到三个人。所以目标不一定是花难以置信的时间去寻找绝对最好的人，并榨干面试的每一分每一秒，
experience to be absolutely flawless right and this is knowing this actually helped me a lot even as an interviewee like i'll get rejected i don't apply that much to jobs anymore to be honest but uh there was a time where i was really you know when i was changing jobs like a few years ago i was applying a lot of jobs and in the past like sometimes i'll get rejected for really weird reasons or things seem like they'll be going fine and then radio silence and uh what i've realized is that the system is trying to trade off you know the manager's time with you know having the perfect possible interview experience and so um and so and so if you have a bunch of mistakes on your resume, the manager will say like, this is going to eat up a lot of my time.
以达到绝对完美。知道这一点甚至对我作为面试者也很有帮助。我会被拒绝，老实说，我现在不怎么投简历了。但在我换工作的时候，几年前，我投了很多工作。过去，有时我会因为非常奇怪的原因被拒绝，或者事情看起来进展顺利，然后就杳无音信。我意识到，系统是在经理的时间和获得完美的面试体验之间进行权衡。所以，如果你的简历上有一堆错误，经理会说，这会占用我大量时间。
Uh, I can just skip this resume and get somebody who's probably as good and save myself from having to ask all these clarifying questions. Right. So mistakes are really, uh, uh, not good. Try to avoid them. Look at the resume. Make sure that you don't have a cover letter that's for the wrong company. I've seen things like that. And just be really diligent. It's important. I think the other thing that is a mistake is i have seen grammar mistakes are not
我可以跳过这份简历，找一个可能同样优秀的人，省去问所有这些澄清问题的麻烦。所以，错误真的非常不好。尽量避免它们。检查简历。确保你没有发错公司的求职信。我见过这样的事情。一定要非常勤奋。这很重要。我认为另一个错误是，我见过语法错误，
and i'm okay with that because not everyone has english as their first language but sometimes like spelling mistakes to where you said like it creates ambiguity it's like i don't actually know what they're saying here um and especially if you're looking for someone on it like they did this one thing and this one thing tells me maybe they have prior experience here and it's written in a way where i can't parse what it's supposed to be saying like jason said that the company i do right now like there isn't even really a good mechanism for me because i can't reach out to that person directly so i have to go back to hr ask hr to reach back out and like hey can you act like this is not a thing that likely happens unless I really, really thought there was good potential in a resume.
我对此没意见，因为不是每个人的母语都是英语。但有时拼写错误会导致歧义，我真的不知道他们在这里想说什么。特别是如果你在寻找某人，他们做了这件事，而这件事告诉我也许他们有相关经验，但写得让我无法解析它想表达的意思。就像 Jason 说的，我现在所在的公司，甚至没有一个好的机制让我直接联系那个人，所以我必须回到人力资源部，让 HR 去联系他们。嘿，除非我真的认为简历有很好的潜力，否则这不太可能发生。
And so you can get kind of bumped out for for relatively small. So have people who aren't like just family, have your family read it and just say, like, is this reasonably clear to you, even though you may not understand some of the terms? Do you see any spelling mistakes? You know, that kind of thing yep um another very simple one uh don't put images so um my company yours probably too patrick uh pulls the text out of the resume and so um uh images really mess that up i've seen this where it's just the information is just totally corrupt. And then you have to click on the resume and all of that.
所以你可能会因为相对较小的原因被淘汰。所以让不是家人的其他人读一下，问他们：“这对你来说足够清晰吗？即使你可能不理解其中的一些术语？你看到任何拼写错误吗？”类似的事情。是的，另一个非常简单的，不要放图片。所以，我的公司，可能你的也是，Patrick，会从简历中提取文本。所以图片真的会把提取搞得一团糟。我见过这种情况，信息完全乱码了。然后你必须点击简历才能看到。
And so this is probably folks who didn't even make it through the screen because of all sorts of weird artifacts that came out of the images in the resume. So just avoid that. There's not really a reason to do that. Related is, and we're going to to do this but i'll just combine them here it's not just images but people will use like colored sections like oh you know gray and then a darker gray for like each experience of work to get visual separation looks great i don't know whatever some of the i think they get printed on a fax machine and then scanned in sometimes we end up with them they're super super hard to read. The contrast is destroyed. The text extraction could fail under such circumstances. If you go
所以这可能是那些因为简历中图片产生的各种奇怪伪影而甚至没能通过筛选的人。所以尽量避免这样做。没有理由这样做。相关的是，我们要把它们合并在一起，不仅仅是图片，人们还会使用彩色部分，比如灰色，然后用深灰色来区分每一段工作经历，为了视觉上的分隔，看起来很棒，我不知道，不管怎样，有些我认为它们是在传真机上打印出来的，然后被扫描进去，有时我们最终得到的版本超级难读。对比度被破坏了。在这种情况下，文本提取可能会失败。如果你去
to a job fair and you're handing a physical resume, sometimes like that's the one that goes in the system, even if you upload one later. So just be aware, like in my opinion, two things, one, don't use a fancy template, like with lots of image bullets and like think like just like very as simple as it can it needs to look nice but it doesn't need to be complex to be looking nice uh and try not to don't certainly not using any colors besides black and white would be my opinion try to keep it black and white try to make sure it's like the most parsable like the easiest to scan and if someone gets a black and white copy or a decimated version of what you uploaded. And so really, really do keep it simple. And this is specific to our slice of engineering. If you're an artist or applying for
招聘会，递交一份纸质简历，有时这就是进入系统的版本，即使你后来上传了电子版。所以要注意，在我看来，两件事：第一，不要使用花哨的模板，带有大量的图片符号，保持越简单越好。它需要看起来不错，但不需要复杂。尽量不要使用除黑白以外的任何颜色，这是我的建议。尽量保持黑白，确保它是最易于解析、最容易扫描的。如果有人拿到的是黑白复印件或你上传版本的降质版。所以，真的，真的要保持简单。这是我们工程领域特有的。如果你是艺术家或申请
a summer job, some, I don't know, those probably have their own sort of ways people like, maybe a spritz of cologne or something on their resume helps. I don't know, but none of that's going to help here. And like, it's just going to create more problems. Yeah, totally. I mean, my, um, my college experience, I built a lot of different things. Um, and I really wanted to show that off, but you should send people to landing pages for those things so my resume was all black and white but it had hyperlinks to the pages which were then then had some nice like design on them but yeah i think the resume is just not the place for that um i just think that you have to appeal to both the people who are looking at it and,
暑期工作，我不知道，那些可能有他们自己喜欢的风格，也许在简历上喷点古龙水之类的会有帮助。我不知道，但这些在这里都没用。这只会制造更多问题。是的，完全同意。我的大学经历中，我构建了很多不同的东西。我真的很想展示出来，但你应该把人们引导到这些东西的落地页，所以我的简历全是黑白的，但上面有超链接，链接到那些设计精美的页面上。但是的，我认为简历不是放这些的地方。我认为你必须同时吸引看简历的人，以及
this sort of lossy, partially automated autonomous system, uh, that's going to do all the pre-screening. And so you have to be careful there. Um, another thing I wouldn't do are, um,
这种有损的、部分自动化的自主系统，它会进行所有的预筛选。所以你必须小心。另外，我不会做的事情是，
you know, put these like qualities of your character. Um, this is actually, I mean, it would be really nice to show your character on your resume. But the problem is, it's just, you know, when people are reading resumes and they come across like hardworking or friendly or something, at best, they just ignore it. Like they have blindness to it.
写上这些性格品质。这其实，如果能在简历上展示你的性格会很好。但问题是，当人们阅读简历时，看到“勤奋”或“友好”之类的词，充其量，他们只是忽略它。就像他们对这些词有盲点一样。
I mean, this is our 30th resume they've looked at today and it's just, they just ignore it. Like they have blindness to it. And this is our 30th resume they've looked at today. And it's just, they skip over it at worst. It does seem like a little bit weird, right? Because, uh, um, it just, it's just weird for someone to call themselves friendly or motivated or hardworking. Um, I think again, similar to what we said with languages you know if you're hard working then find objective things that you did so for example let's say you built a hundred houses a year for habitat for humanity like physically built the houses well then that shows you're super hard working right so just put that um so you know find a like how have these social qualities resulted in some objective thing that you've done in the world and and just put that thing yep i agree and i mean this extends to the interview we're not talking about interview prep right now but
我的意思是，这是他们今天看的第 30 份简历，他们只是忽略了它。就像他们对这些词有盲点一样。这是他们今天看的第 30 份简历。他们只是跳过了它。最坏的情况是，这看起来有点奇怪，对吧？因为一个人称自己为友好、积极或勤奋，这很奇怪。我认为，再次强调，就像我们说语言时那样，如果你勤奋，那就找出你做过的客观事情。例如，假设你为仁人家园每年建造一百所房子，是亲手建造的，那么这表明你非常勤奋。所以写上那个。所以，找到这些社会品质是如何转化为你在世界上完成的客观事情的，然后写上那件事。是的，我同意。我的意思是，这延伸到了面试，我们现在不是在谈论面试准备，但
everybody's on their best behavior on resumes and on the thing for the most part so if anything so two things one everybody's saying they're hard working and motivated and willing to work long hours or whatever they think like i'm not saying anyone should or does do that but like whatever they think will you know get them the job everyone is pretty much trying to do and on the other side the people doing the interview assume those things so they assume that people are on their best behavior and are that way and so like jason said it's really better to show than to tell um and if you need to put it like like don't don't make it too flowery like it just because then people think you're kind of like overcompensating for something like why are they saying they're so hard working um you know it's very weird yep yep totally agree i
在简历和面试中，大多数人都会表现出最好的一面。所以有两点：第一，每个人都说自己勤奋、有动力、愿意长时间工作等等，我并不是说有人应该或确实会那样做，但无论他们认为什么能让他们得到这份工作，每个人基本上都在尝试这样做。另一方面，面试官也预设了这些情况，他们认为应聘者会表现出最好的一面，确实就是那样。所以正如杰森所说，展示出来比说出来更好。如果你需要写出来，不要写得太花哨，因为那样人们会觉得你在过度补偿，会想‘为什么他们要强调自己这么勤奋？’这会显得很奇怪。是的，完全同意。
think uh um you know we didn't really have this in the do section kind of but we'll cover it now is i do think it's important to call out your um what do you call it what would you call this section uh basically like i think it's like hobbies and activities yeah you know extracurriculars yeah Yeah, extracurricular. Yeah, exactly. So, you know, one thing I put on my early resumes was that, you know, I ran like a volleyball team. I played in like three different volleyball leagues. And so I gave people the impression like, OK, here's somebody who like can be on a team, can lead a team, can like play a sport pretty regularly for a long period of time. And I think that way I didn't have to put things like, like motivated or something or friendly or something. So, so yeah, definitely.
我想，虽然我们在‘要做的事’部分没有真正提到，但现在可以补充一下，我认为列出你的……你管这部分叫什么？基本上就是爱好和活动，对吧？课外活动。是的，就是课外活动。我早期的简历上写过我组织过排球队，参加过三个不同的排球联赛。这给了人们一种印象：这是一个能融入团队、能领导团队、能长期坚持参加体育运动的人。这样我就不必写‘有动力’、‘友好’之类的词了。所以，这绝对是有用的。
I think extracurriculars are good. I wouldn't put things that are controversial because again, it's like if something is really polemic, right. And, and half the people will love you, half the people will not like you. I don't think the people who love you are going to pass you in the interview if you're not competent. But I do think the people who don't like you will make your interview really difficult.
我认为课外活动很好，但我不会写有争议的内容。因为如果某件事非常有争议，一半人会喜欢你，另一半人会不喜欢你。我不认为那些喜欢你的人会在你能力不足时让你通过面试，但我认为那些不喜欢你的人会让你的面试变得非常困难。
And so it's kind of a lose-lose situation. So I would avoid putting things that, you know are are just like polemic like that but but you know for things like sports you know charitable things i mean these things are great for your resume so i i think a little bit about briefly resources how to produce your resume so because of all the other things we've already been saying i think it's pretty much any reasonable text editor would be fine but even just using google docs to produce it it really shouldn't have requirements that it be fancy and needs to be done and you know adobe illustrator or I mean, if you want to do that,
这是一种双输的局面。所以我建议避免写那些有争议的内容。但对于体育、慈善活动等，这些对简历来说很棒。关于如何制作简历，考虑到我们之前说的所有内容，我认为任何合理的文本编辑器都可以。甚至只用谷歌文档来制作也行，真的不需要把它做得太花哨，也不需要用Adobe Illustrator之类的软件。当然，如果你想用那些软件，
it's probably because you're looking for a job related to that. But for our field, at least, I think it should be able to, you know, Google Docs is free on the on the Mac, as you have pages or Microsoft Word, just something that in general is, you know, text focused and does allow you a little bit of formatting. I mean, to format it to look nice, but don't go overboard. Yep. And just a general rule, if you're doing something, you really want to think about the audience, right? And so this is a, I'm going to link a podcast that I listened to that's geared towards managers. It's literally called manager tools, the podcast. And, um, um they're they have an episode it's actually a five-part series on how to scan resumes and so like putting yourselves in the shoes of someone who's looking at your resume i think can really help you uh in writing your resume so if they say
那可能是因为你在找相关的工作。但至少在我们这个领域，我认为应该能够使用谷歌文档，或者Mac上的Pages，或者微软Word，只要是通用的、以文本为重点且允许进行少量格式设置的工具就行。我的意思是，格式化得好看一点是可以的，但不要做得太过火。是的。一个通用的原则是，如果你在做某事，你真的需要考虑受众。我将分享一个我听过的播客，它是专门为管理者准备的，名字就叫《管理者工具》（Manager Tools）。他们有一个关于如何筛选简历的五集系列节目。把自己放在看简历的人的角度，我认为这真的能帮助你写好简历。如果他们说
something like you know if there's too many colors just throw it in the garbage and you're looking at your resume that you created in adobe illustrator yeah it'll kind of put things in perspective um so so yeah i think this is a great chance to see kind of what other people see when they look at your resume by listening to that episode that's great um and then i think you put this on here but i mean for the programmers out there using la tech uh to do their uh markdown version of the resume i guess is a is an option it's going to get made into a a pdf anyway so i i guess that's an option is that is that how you do it yeah you know the oh the reason i used la tech is for a CV, it helps with the references.
比如‘如果颜色太多，直接扔进垃圾桶’，而你看着自己用Adobe Illustrator制作的简历，这会让你换个角度看问题。所以，我认为通过听那期节目，看看别人在看你的简历时看到了什么，是一个很好的机会。那太棒了。另外，我想你提到了这一点，对于程序员来说，使用LaTeX来制作简历的Markdown版本也是一种选择，反正最后都会生成PDF。我想这是一种选择，你是这样做的吗？是的，我使用LaTeX是因为它是学术简历（CV），它有助于处理参考文献。
Now I remember. But I wouldn't recommend that. Even if you're a PhD student, there's probably better ways to do it nowadays. I think the important thing is what Patrick said. Use the tool you're comfortable with and the tool that is pretty popular. And don't try and do it in in an image processing tool and create something that's really uh ad hoc uh layout wise all right well the wrap like last statement here i think we're running a bit long but hopefully this is useful i think for a lot of these things
现在我想起来了。但我不会推荐这样做。即使你是博士生，现在也有更好的方法。我认为重要的是帕特里克所说的：使用你熟悉的、流行的工具。不要试图用图像处理工具来制作，也不要搞出那种布局上非常随意的简历。好了，最后总结一下，虽然我们时间有点长了，但希望这些内容有用。我认为对于很多事情，
one of like jason was mentioning is um if you want to say you're hard working show your hard working put down things that indicate that you're hardworking, show you're hardworking, put down things that indicate that you're hardworking. And I think it isn't the only goal, but when you are picking projects to work on at your job or careers or hobbies to do, thinking about how they may show on a resume is worth considering, right? I think not because the resume matters a ton, but because you're thinking about that as part of career development. And part of having a career is having hobbies outside of that, but having the ability to show your potential as an employee. And so I think putting thought into how am I going to choose what to work on? And what is it going to
就像杰森提到的，如果你想说你很勤奋，那就展示出来。写下那些能证明你勤奋的事情。我认为这不仅仅是一个目标，当你选择工作中的项目、职业方向或爱好时，考虑它们如何体现在简历上是值得的。不是因为简历有多重要，而是因为这是职业发展的一部分。拥有职业生涯的一部分是拥有业余爱好，但也要有展示你作为员工潜力的能力。所以，思考一下‘我该如何选择工作内容？’以及它会
look like, you know, later. So as an example, if I was reading something this morning, oh, COBOL, there's a dearth of COBOL engineers. So at work, someone might say, hey, we have this COBOL code, we really want you to take on, you should think, is that something that I really want for my future? Is it something that in a way of thinking about that? Is that something I really want to put on my resume? Like, am I going to want another job in COBOL? I mean, to be fair, it could be really lucrative. It's an interesting bet if there really is going to be a, you know, scarcity of COBOL engineers, but if it's not something that's going to make sense there, then you might want to find and see if there's an alternative or something else within, within reason, Not again, as maybe the only thing you think about,
看起来怎么样，这很重要。举个例子，我今天早上读到关于COBOL的内容，现在非常缺乏COBOL工程师。在工作中，如果有人说‘嘿，我们有这段COBOL代码，我们真的希望你接手’，你应该思考：‘这是我未来真正想要的吗？这是我简历上想写的东西吗？我以后还想找COBOL相关的工作吗？’公平地说，这可能非常有利可图。如果真的会出现COBOL工程师短缺，这是一个有趣的赌注。但如果这不符合你的职业规划，那么你可能需要寻找替代方案，或者在合理范围内做其他事情。当然，这不应该是你唯一考虑的事情，
but trying to consider how that might look. People do this all the time for university applications. They think in high school, what should I be doing to get into a good university? You're going to work a job probably a lot longer, can work a lot longer. People can work four or five, six, seven years. So even putting a little bit of thought towards over that time, how do I compound things that will help me be marketable is very
但尝试考虑它看起来会怎样。人们在申请大学时总是这样做。他们在高中时会想：‘我应该做什么才能进入一所好大学？’你可能会工作很长时间，人们可以工作四、五年、六、七年。所以，花点心思考虑一下随着时间的推移，我如何积累那些能让我更具市场竞争力的东西，这是非常
important. And I think as a manager, it's something that I try to think about for my employees is I'm not trying to retain them by making them unmarketable. I'm trying to make them feel like they can stay here by continuing to let them do things in a way that would be very marketable because then they're going to feel no need to, that they're trapped, right? They're doing things that they know they could parlay into other careers or other jobs, other places, which makes them content and happy and growing. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. Yeah, I mean, that's a great call out. I think just the last sort of call to action is you're if you're in college, you might think that you're.
重要的。作为一名管理者，我也会为我的员工考虑这一点。我不是试图通过让他们失去市场竞争力来留住他们。我试图让他们觉得可以留在这里，通过让他们继续做那些非常有市场价值的事情，因为这样他们就不会觉得被困住了。他们做的事情是他们知道可以转化为其他职业、其他工作或去其他地方发展的，这让他们感到满足、快乐并不断成长。是的，这非常有道理。这是一个很好的提醒。最后一个行动号召是，如果你还在上大学，你可能会认为
The work to kind of like build yourself up is kind of over like, oh, I get my job and I never have to look at this resume again. I can just throw it in the garbage. But but no, like you're you're. I think it's always good to kind of keep that in mind. I mean, definitely there's several different reasons to take on a project or a job, but that's definitely one that you should keep up there. Cool. All right. This is awesome. We covered a lot of good material if folks out there have
自我提升的工作已经结束了，比如‘哦，我找到了工作，再也不用看这份简历了，我可以把它扔进垃圾桶’。但事实并非如此。我认为时刻保持这种意识总是好的。当然，选择一个项目或工作有多种原因，但这绝对是你应该考虑的一个因素。太棒了。我们涵盖了很多好的内容，如果大家有
other resources other tips feel free to uh you know throw it on the discord or on the patreon uh group um thanks everyone who um have given us their patronage on on patreon we really appreciate it um i did ask in the members only section um what kind of uh perks do folks want do folks want to have like a zoom call with us uh do they want us to look at their resumes like what sort of like patreon uh benefits are folks interested in and um you know i think there's a as pat Patrick used the word earlier, sort of a survivorship bias here where the folks who are in our Patreon really just want to thank us for the content that we give everyone for free. We do really appreciate that. But I'll ask to the general audience as well, if there is something, you know, interesting that you think we can do as part of the patreon experience
其他资源或建议，请随时在Discord或Patreon群组中分享。感谢所有在Patreon上支持我们的人，我们非常感激。我在会员专区问过大家想要什么样的福利，比如是否想要和我们进行Zoom通话，或者是否希望我们查看他们的简历。大家对什么样的Patreon福利感兴趣？正如帕特里克之前提到的，这里存在一种‘幸存者偏差’，Patreon上的朋友们只是想感谢我们免费提供的内容。我们真的很感激。但我也会问问广大听众，如果有什么你们认为我们可以作为Patreon体验的一部分来做的有趣事情，
uh always just throw us an email uh throw a growing throwdown at gmail.com or uh you know throw it on the discord or or in uh in patreon thanks a lot thank you everyone Thank you. to share like and kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随时给我们发电子邮件，发送到throwingdown@gmail.com，或者在Discord或Patreon上留言。非常感谢大家。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。